Songs that the whole name of the song.
Yep.
That's it.
That's the whole name of the song.
There's no need for the fucking music young Jamie.
I like that.
That was the beginning of it.
That's it.
Oh,
mother fucking live.
we're doing it here.
We're doing it.
Oh,
nice.
That's a great note.
They bizarre.
Yeah,
I like it.
Yeah.
Happy with it.
Ori motherfucking CIF fear has a billboard.
If there was a movie about your life,
um,
and then this happened the way it happened,
I would go,
uh,
they didn't,
I was too much.
Yeah,
too true.
Troy.
No Way.
Oh,
I had a billboard above where I lived for 10 years as he struggled.
Yeah.
As he was fucking destitute,
living in this little shitty area of Hollywood,
like 13 grand a year,
right next to the comedy store.
Right down the street from the comedy store is the cheapest housing near the
comedy store.
Yeah.
I remember every time I'd visit you and be like,
we're safe here.
Can we walk through this?
Everything.
All right.
You live with,
it wasn't dangerous,
but it was bad.
And then eventually the homeless people started moving in.
Yeah.
You lived with some sketchy folk?
Oh,
sure.
There was only a few people were like,
I didn't walk through your halls.
Like I would walk through the Ritz Carlton's
pillows.
Like I was on a,
I wouldn't say I'm on,
Oh,
you know,
Code Red,
but I was on code yellow or whatever the fuck the terrorist code is.
I had a little bit of,
we had this,
these er,
these horns.
There's kind of like that,
that Brady,
uh,
that chain you have there,
this thing with the beads.
Yeah.
It was hanging up with this weird horn thing,
like on the railing and a corner.
And I asked my friend there,
I was like,
how long has this been there?
Because before I moved in and were like,
do you want move?
You fucking move it.
It just looked like Voodoo ish.
And we were like,
maybe it's keeping the place up and nothing was there for 10,
12 years and you haven't touched it.
And you had this great deal where this apartment,
like they wanted to turn it into something else and they want to say it's prime
real estate.
Sunset and Laci undergo son,
son Los [inaudible].
They put a dope apartment building up in there.
People would kind of want to do,
but everyone above and the hill,
the Richie's got mad.
They're like,
you're going to block our view.
Ah,
the rich.
And they blocked it forever.
Plus even if it was like,
all right,
all the new one,
there'll be no blockage of you.
I'm going to put a rooftop garden on there.
So all you'll see is greenery and flowers.
Um,
about that.
Still not,
it's going to mess up traffic while you're building.
He goes,
yeah,
it is going to mess up traffic a little.
And then he got a deal with pink dot.
He goes,
how about we only enter through the pink dot parking lot?
And they were like,
still not.
Yeah,
that takes years,
right?
Yeah.
So that he finally got the okay.
People were moving out one by one.
He was given deals to people and he gave you a deal.
Give me a deal.
I got the deal.
I think I might have in the last one to get the deal.
Ari's always been so swamped talking,
looking out here,
but you've always been so like for a comic you've always been so smart with
money.
Well,
I knew that as soon as I was out of money,
I was out of this dream.
[inaudible]
my,
my amount of money I had was time.
So if I had five grand in the bank,
that's six months before I had to quit and moved back to Maryland,
go to paralegal school,
whatever it was.
You were never moving back.
Dude,
I would've never let you move back.
So I don't know.
I would have never let you move back.
I would've fucking kidnapped you.
Maybe your body guard.
Well,
I,
I knew when we first met,
there's certain comics where you meet them when they're really young and you go,
dude,
all you have to do is just keep going.
Just keep going.
Yeah,
you could do this.
There's guys that you go,
man,
I don't know.
Like there's guys who became like super successful.
Like Sebastian is a really good example.
I got to see Sebastian really early in his career and he's a really funny comic.
You really,
really,
really fun.
Yeah,
but he wasn't back then.
It wasn't until admitted.
We will all look.
I wasn't either when I was young,
somebody,
if they're really bad,
you'd be like,
you should maybe quit like a year or two lady like,
oh,
okay.
You're starting to get it.
If you saw me when I was one year in,
I mean fucking Christ,
you probably would've told me to quit.
I was terrible.
I was 21 I was an idiot.
I didn't know anything about anything in life.
I told you what times four is,
you're showing me your math skills.
I totally said,
what's seven times four?
It's an easy one.
You were like 11 and you're like,
no,
you're awful.
But then you realize like,
okay,
maybe you're starting to get this.
You at least know that you can add those things.
Yeah.
Well,
you have 10 that eventually you get experience.
You have to have life experience.
I didn't have life experience.
I didn't even have regular people's life experiences.
All new comics do jokes about not being able to get laid is young.
Fucking uncomfortable.
People can't get late.
That's most of their experience.
I know you don't want to fuck me and it's like,
yeah,
I tell everybody thinks a 24 yeah,
but when you're a comic and you'd been a comic for a long time,
you see someone who's doing it like they're starting out.
There was some kid on kill Tony.
Yeah,
I had a conversation with them afterwards.
I go,
dude,
you really funny that you can really do this.
Like we had this long conversation,
like how long have you been doing this?
He's like,
two years.
I go do,
you're really good.
You could do this.
I could just keep going.
Just keep,
you got to just keep,
just keep going.
Just got to keep going.
One another secret you'll take.
There's no secrets,
man.
Just keep going.
But that's what I knew with you.
You know,
artists gave me advice.
I might have told you this.
I went through my first Rudd where like everything was hitting a little worse.
If it was like an a plus room,
my jokes that should get at,
but we're getting like a B plus and you're like an a be room.
They were getting a c and I'm like,
I don't know what's happening here.
These jokes do better.
And I asked a bunch of people for advice and you were like,
yeah,
you're,
we've grown pastor material so he's got to get new material.
Freddy was like,
do it like a thousand times so you'd know it so well it's not a hundred times.
But that argus gave me this advice that he goes,
well,
maybe comedy is not your thing.
And I was like so mad about,
oh my God.
The reality as he was talking to some young new guy who's like,
I don't know man,
it's not going well.
And he's like,
the fucking,
I can see what his point of view.
It's like,
well if you don't want to do this you should get out.
Well,
our guests has been doing it way longer than me and he was at the store for like
in like the seventies late seventies so like,
he's probably so tired of hearing that.
Yeah,
dude,
shut up.
Shut up to if you want to do it or don't.
But you know what man,
those guys,
I feel like they do the art form of disservice because I think that people,
not argus in general,
we like people who don't take time to talk to young comics.
They think of talent because comics are super fragile in the beginning because
one of the reasons why I was like always like really friendly to mark Marin for
like years after,
before we've,
why we like had some weirdness with each other.
He gave me advice when I was,
when I was like really young when I was like 21 and I was just doing open mic
nights.
Yeah,
I did the comedy connection.
Once he gave me advice,
he said,
he goes,
dude.
He goes,
you're really good.
you could do this.
He said,
um,
he goes,
just don't listen to all these other people.
He goes,
you're really original.
You got your own thing you're doing.
He said,
just keep writing.
Just keep writing.
Yeah,
and I remember like,
man was like a successful comic.
Then you know,
he was like a,
he would work,
you know,
he would like,
there'd be a show,
they'd be Jackie Flynn,
Mark Merritt,
like he was on the marquee or the whatever he was on the lineup.
He was getting paid.
If you're a new guy,
look up at someone,
anyone like that.
It's like,
wow,
you're doing this for a living.
That was so important to me.
And so I think that when I remember that like back in those days,
I mean when,
when someone can come along and just give you just a little nudge,
just a little piece and then you have to realize where we're all the same God
damn thing in this,
this idea,
this just because you've been doing it longer.
Like a guy who's been doing it for like six months,
he's a real comic.
He's still a comic.
He's a comic book.
It doesn't matter that it's broken poor.
He's been doing it for six months.
He's you,
dude.
We're the same thing.
I'll try to write a good picture.
Okay.
We want to get to pretend you're something different once you're successful.
That's ridiculous.
That sounds so crazy.
Like every,
all you're trying to do is make people laugh.
That's all you're trying to do.
That's all they're trying to do.
The same thing.
Even if people,
more people going to see you or more people want to see another guy,
that's not what matters.
What matters is like Russell Peters,
perfect example.
Russell Peters treats everybody like they're comics.
He treats everybody.
Young guys,
this company wants who's talking to the front hallway.
Tommy was working the cover booth and he was also a teller coordinator and,
uh,
there were just talking in the front and,
um,
Russell's like,
you're good on Ya.
And he goes,
until he was like,
no,
he wasn't passed as a paid regular yet.
And he goes,
no,
I don't really,
uh,
it's not,
you could tell he was already upset about it,
but he said,
what do you mean you don't get up here?
He goes,
you know,
in the belly room sometimes,
and then Russell just turns the Tom.
He goes,
hey man,
you should put him up.
He's really funny.
You kidding?
You've got to put him up.
The guy like Tommy,
you could,
you could do that.
Yeah,
you can overpower.
And it's like,
yeah,
well why not tell somebody like,
okay,
tell me.
I'll email the right.
Just write that and it's like,
Hey,
do it.
This guy's funny.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
I um,
whoa.
Remember when Chris Mcguire passed at the store and I hosted the whole night
because you don't understand Peter Chin was going to host and he was the worst
comment.
I still get emails from them sometimes.
These new pilots he's made,
he was beyond terrible.
He was like a foreign Asian who had nothing.
He had nothing.
He was there to exist for dom bears to fuck with.
He's going to be very upset at you over is going to be very upset that you know,
he's on his pilots.
He's age.
I watched him every time he's out there trying,
they're like 38 minutes as a pilot or like four minutes as a pilot.
They make no sense.
Oh,
they're so great dunk.
He thought he was just doing a character.
So you had to sit next to Mitzi.
Oh yeah.
You got people past sit next to them and laugh.
She's actually watch.
That's how I got in.
I got in because of the tod.
The Todd sat there,
they,
Todd hooked me up and he told me he was hooked me up and he told me,
you do it to other comics too or heard Louis called for this guy I worked with
in San Francisco and I needed a,
an an MC and she was like,
well,
there's a,
who am I?
Somebody good,
please get somebody really good.
But anyway,
Louis called the punchline for this guy,
so I'm somewhere and he was like,
Hey,
that guy's funny,
so you should help him.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Yeah man,
that's important for all of us were we,
you know,
we're also fans of it,
right.
I want to be.
I want to see other,
I want to be in the audience.
Want to see funny shit.
Yeah dudes.
Now federal do really good.
So here's,
here's the Ra center story.
So he's living in his fucking apartment.
Okay.
This is crazy apartment.
It did have a pool.
It was fucking sweet for the price.
It was Scott Damn sweet.
Oh Yeah Dude,
you had to hook good hookup.
I mean it wasn't totally dangerous mean,
you know,
but like they wouldn't want to do the,
once people started moving out,
they don't want to do any repairs.
So it was just like leaves were around.
It looked like the apocalypse.
It hit like walking dead.
But they found a place I've had a literal slum lord for.
Yeah,
we had a slumlord.
I'm more a real one.
He would always accuse us of that too.
It was like,
dude,
do the fucking repair man.
And he's like you saying I'm a slum Lord.
It's like,
oh,
but yes you are.
Fix The fucking clean the fucking pool.
Looking at him,
he gets so angry cause he had to and he just wouldn't want to do is fucking
Armeen mean anyways.
Whoa,
whoa.
Worst how dirt was coming out of my,
my sink once.
And I'm like,
dude,
dirt is coming out of this.
And he goes,
that's what happens.
You haven't used a second a while.
I'm like,
let me come to your place and see if happens at your place in Malibu.
Wow.
Fuck you frank.
Whoa,
whoa.
All right.
She fear.
Okay.
So anyway,
he's living in this apartment and you know,
there was a point in time where things weren't going that good for a large point
in time,
like 10,
12 years.
You were,
you know,
putting in your time and you were trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
Um,
but what was important during that time,
it was really,
really,
really important during that time is,
um,
even though you weren't achieving like great financial success,
you were doing well on stage.
Yeah.
It was,
I was having people like me at my level.
I was always like one of the better ones,
I think always doing well.
And you were,
you were always working,
you were always working on new shit.
You always are trying to get better.
You're always like tweaking things and you know,
kind of like we all do.
We all,
we all have a real similar style in that.
Like we don't have like a monologue that's prepared and that exact same way all
the time.
The store guys can't do that.
Yeah.
Like can we come for a showcase for like Montreal or s or Conan or something?
Six months.
I have to just start to go up,
go.
So I was at the store ever notice comedy store guys fail at that when there's
eight people in the audience comedy store,
people fail.
Can't just go right into material.
Yeah.
They're like,
this is not what I supposed to do here.
I should do crowd work for seven people.
So I'm not,
yeah,
we can't do it.
It just seems weird because that plays control used to the honesty that flights
contrivance and then here you are needing to,
we can try it.
So yeah.
So go ahead.
Sorry.
And is doing,
you know he's doing stand up at the store.
Uh,
I uh,
I started taking you on the road.
That's how you found me.
What'd you find me?
Well,
how'd you find me?
Another store,
but yeah,
but we were friendly and stuff.
You were cool.
You hung out,
you know,
but like how'd you go from that to like,
hey come open for me once because I saw that there was something going on,
man.
Don't you even come by for the open mic or maybe that was my family room was
there all the time.
I lived at the store basically.
Yeah.
When I was doing stand up in the early nineties,
from 94 to like whatever it was that I stopped going there,
I was probably doing late spas.
Probably already paid records,
doing late night spots by now.
I saw you before you were paid regular dude,
I saw you way before.
You're paid regular.
We became friends when you were first starting out there.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
You were working there,
you were working there.
You were one of the kids working there were always cool.
We are always talking in the parking lot and no.
Yeah.
You used to get me high.
You had that,
you had that up marijuana soda once before anybody knew what it was.
It is.
That dates me couldn't get where you are still at the feet of Buddy Bolton
learning how to fucking free pot game.
Yeah.
I would say Bolton.
Was that his name?
Which guy?
The Guy who first had like the medical marijuana license.
Yeah.
Was that his last name?
Bolton.
Buddy Bolton.
Thanks.
That sounds right.
Yeah,
he was a cool dude.
Whatever.
I totally cool.
I don't know his pictures up in the cellar of those like Mana montage montage
pictures,
but anyway.
Damn.
But yeah,
and it was like you couldn't go to a store and buy it.
It was just legal if you had this card,
but it wasn't like you had to be suitable as fuck.
And I was getting mine from the um,
displace in um,
in the hood.
Got It.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was in the hood.
I was trying to run my,
kept the card for like the longest time.
Inglewood.
Inglewood though.
Inglewood wellness center.
That's what it's called.
And one of the verbal nice and Nice,
nicest folks that run that place there was so nice.
And um,
when um,
I hadn't been there for a while and I was thinking about,
man,
I should go down there and buy something from them just to give them some love
cause they're really nice guys.
But one of the guys got shot.
Really?
Yeah.
One of the guys got robbed there.
Done point and shot in the stomach.
Fuck yeah.
And he lived but I'm like,
Whoa,
what am I doing?
They got,
they got robbed because they had a lot of money on hand cash because they were
taking everything in cash.
And uh,
most,
most of them didn't have credit cards until fairly recently.
Right,
right,
right.
Cash.
So they were selling weed.
Everybody knew they were selling weed and so they got robbed and he got shot.
Oh,
it's hard to talk about that man.
That sucks.
Gentle people.
If you knew that you guys them and they're like,
we can take advantage of this.
If you knew the dude who got shot,
he was such a gentle guy.
He just is such an less like a sweetheart,
like what you think of as a classic like older stoner came out really doing man.
Good to see you brother.
Good.
See you.
Give me a hug man.
How are you man?
You're like everything cool.
Always friendly.
Always like positive.
And they would laugh and laugh and crack jokes and just talk about,
we'd talk about life and all kinds of shit and this guy got shot selling weed
so I stopped going there.
But yeah,
but the region brought around was fucking tremendous.
Those guys hooked it up back in the day.
I mean this is like 99 or something like that.
What year was I started?
I started 2009 so this is 2000 2001 yeah,
somewhere around there.
Makes Sense.
Cause that's around when I started hanging out with Eddie Bravo,
he started [inaudible],
he corrupted me up to me and I corrupted you.
I called you,
I refer to Rogan as LDL below for about seven months cause that'd be at the fun
run.
It'd be one 45 in the morning.
I put oil,
the chairs.
I'm just sitting in the front chair looking out at sunset so high and just
thinking,
get out of me,
get out of me.
And it wouldn't leave.
Do we had some fun?
We did shows where we were so high we should definitely not have been talking to
people.
Anybody.
They went,
great,
man.
You just gotta Kinda [inaudible] in those days on stage,
I would just get high to be around.
You got high.
I'm going on stage a bunch of times though.
Back then later.
Yeah.
The one in Boston,
one of Boston's flood.
That was the first time.
That was the first time Rogan's refused to let me not get hot.
He goes,
hey,
let's get hot going.
The hotel was like across the street and they were like,
I was up there.
I mean,
come on man.
We gotta go.
He's like,
all right,
quick and high first.
So I was like,
what?
I hope you'll be onstage and looking 18 minutes and you were like,
Nah,
who cares?
I'm like,
no,
I won't be able to be good.
He goes,
who do you think you work for it work with this fortune 80 seat room or that you
work for me?
And I was like,
yeah,
I guess you would say.
He goes,
I don't care if you fail so fucking get high.
What was important to me to tell you is that you can't get fired.
Right.
That's what it was.
Nothing bad will happen.
Yeah.
You can't,
can't get fired.
Your learning how to do this.
You'd only been doing it a couple of years.
You're writing jokes,
you're trying to shit out.
I'm like,
just go up there and have some fun,
be you.
But I was not how the tolerance,
uh,
you were at [inaudible] and I go,
oh,
they beat me in the second show by the second show,
the first show I would were on fire on the second show though.
You were on fire.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Because you had gotten into this like crazy place where you like,
when you get high,
there's this point in the beginning where you're like,
ah,
it's dangerous.
The danger zone.
I'm skiing.
That'll that that'll make you,
yeah,
exactly.
You skiing,
you're going down a mountain
and that's what makes you leave parties early.
You gotta,
you gotta overcome the danger zone.
Woo.
And then it takes you into what?
Then you get into this introspective w really articulates zone,
get into an area where you're more articulate than you are when you're not cool.
I think it's over the,
over the top of the mountain.
So then you're like,
okay,
I know that's as high as I was going to get.
Yeah,
that's hosting.
No,
I'm coasting.
I'm not scared anymore.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's exactly what it is.
You get to this weird point where you're,
you're,
you're kind of,
you're comfortable with the state and then you can kind of relax and also the
effects of the THC of diminished they'll,
they'll diminish over an hour.
That first part is 30 minutes.
For me it was,
it was two and a half hours cause I was slaughter than that man.
Sometimes you're high the next day.
Oh yeah,
you like a cookie or something like that and you could easily be high the next
day.
My friend Aaron got me high in college on the unkind bud.
Do you ever,
do you have kind bud when you are not,
that's just not real.
What does that mean?
Wait,
hold on.
What kind?
But mean just means good pot that's all met,
which is good.
It's just there's this does just pot man.
Here's what in kind bud there was sweat.
Todd Cormack.
Come on,
explain all of this.
He could he give me the guy,
he's coming on soon.
Anyway,
he'll,
he'll come on,
he's doing some giant,
we'd expo in La.
He's going to promote.
Yeah,
but he could tell you the actual history.
Like he's an actual historian guy.
Bud guessing.
He actually went up that met Sativa,
Endeca or put this and go to bed.
I think just whack.
We'd,
there's Mexican dirt weed to Shitty weed tie stuck.
Yeah,
but it's all weed.
But he gave me some and I played golf with my grandma,
my aunt the next day and apply whole five.
I was like just coming down.
I realized when we're hitting the guard,
I remember,
and she's a conservative person,
her husband's a lawyer and like it's conservative.
It's so that it's like once I realized I was high,
I was like,
keep your mouth shut dude.
But if you get that wave right,
like the other night Aubrey and I were playing pool and um,
I don't really play that much anymore man.
I don't get a chance.
I don't play in tournaments anymore.
I don't get a chance to play too many.
Like sometimes dom Arrera and I will get together or Greg Fitzsimmons plays
pretty good.
We'll get together,
you play pretty good and we'll get together and knocks the balls around.
But I'm not like playing like real players.
I can tournaments anymore.
And so I think,
but every now and then like you get high and you remember what to do if you can
remember how to do it.
The other day I got in,
I got in the zone for like five,
six shots in a row.
I started like,
I started running out like this table I should getting out over and over and
over again.
In a way that I really shouldn't be able to do because I'm really not practicing
that much,
but I just got into the zone.
It was very temporary.
I couldn't hold it,
but I knew it was all the weed.
I knew it.
I know I know how to play pool a little bit,
but I'm in this crazy sensitive zone where I know how to control that ball
better.
It's two ways it could hit you.
I do on basketball and sometimes in basketball it's like someone will throw you
a pass and Walton the area go,
okay,
what am I options here?
When this ball gets to me,
I got him cutting.
I could pass to him,
I could shoot,
I could pass it back and it's like,
all right,
I'm ready.
I think I'm right,
and then the ball comes to you at other times that Paul just hits you in the
face.
Sorry.
Got It.
There was like,
why are you buying high?
It's so true.
So true.
Yet that's the same with Jujitsu as well.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
People love smoking pot and doing Jujitsu too because I think it makes you like
focus makes you focus on what you're doing rather than like being uncomfortable
with what you're doing,
let's you like really just be in the moment in some strange way.
It doesn't.
That's counterintuitive for people that are in the store to pot couldn't help
you.
Yeah.
It's also like what we would do when we were,
when we were doing that and we'd get really high and go on stage we were doing
was I was like,
I know that when we get really high and we sit around and talk,
we have some of the funnier things.
Yeah.
It's fun at a riff on that when you're high.
Yes.
Don't matter.
Sets the comedy store good.
Your high where it's like,
let me just tell you a joke and then you just think of something ridiculous on
top of it.
Like you talk about fucking flying giraffe,
pussy people.
Yeah.
Those don't come out unless you're stoned,
so once in a while you need that.
But if you're doing a showcase,
if you're like,
here's the exact set I want to run.
Then it's not the greatest thing in the world to do.
Yeah,
well it's,
yeah,
sometimes it's not right.
It's easy.
Asked me before he takes his special a couple of years ago actually,
what does,
what do you do for weed?
I was like,
I smoked like two hours before,
hour and a half before and you know,
let it,
let it tape it off.
Don't risk having a too high that time,
but yeah,
could be danger.
But if you get past that and you get to that calm spot,
then you real it.
Yeah man.
That's like,
that's where a lot of comedy comes from,
which is,
which is sold the really bad bill of goods and his country when it comes to
marijuana and it just automatically associated with people that are lazy
automatically associated people that are dumb and so smoked more than ever.
Yeah.
I have two specials that I show this year.
It's only the first quarter.
It's not bad.
It's,
it makes you,
it makes you more aware,
makes you more sensitive and that,
that also brings the paranoia.
But I knew that like,
you know,
if you just got used to doing it,
you would love it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Especially when you're fucking around on.
I go back and apologize to the people you shit on for smoking pot.
They would go like,
Oh man who they were.
Yeah.
I wonder what was people that were already like failing.
That was the problem.
The people that I knew that were smoking pot all the time,
but you weren't doing anything with their lives.
I didn't know anybody that was like Joey Diaz.
Ralphie,
people like that.
People that were smoking around the store where their pot smokers back then.
Well I definitely didn't smoke pot when I first met Joey.
Cause when Joey used to hang around the,
uh,
he did not smoke pot.
He definitely smoked pot,
but he ramped it up quite a bit.
I mean he really ramped it up quite a bit when it became more and more aware,
uh,
available in the 90s,
the late nineties and the early two thousands,
like right when I started smoking,
he had already ramped it up.
You know,
he was ramping it up like he was,
he was getting fucking cookies from people back then and he quit and he quit the
coke.
So it's like going to fill in the,
I don't think so.
I think it was,
it was much later.
Oh,
really?
Ramped it up.
We were good friends during the coke days.
Yeah.
Joey and I were real good friends during the coke days and it happened,
it happened like consecutively with the death of my friend Johnny who also,
yeah,
also had a coke thing,
so I knew the coke thing.
I knew,
I knew what it was like to be around those guys.
And uh,
wasn't the same time?
No,
no it was,
you know,
Joey was high long before then and then,
and then the coke thing went,
like,
he went back and forth like into the time where I was already smoking weed.
I remember Joey in some city,
Boston,
Philly,
something like that world driving there with Kik.
I saw these like 18 year old kids like walking in front of our car to the
shoulder where and like,
you know,
flying monkey or whatever you call it,
what it,
what does it talk about your time,
higher primates shirts.
Yeah.
Stuff like that.
And I was like,
oh,
the go to the show.
And then as they passed onto the driver's ideas like Hong Kong and they honk and
they hit,
they turn,
they seed the,
I was like,
well,
we're going to the show right now.
And he's like,
we get there,
like,
we got these cookies.
He just grabs one.
It does it in his mouth and they're like,
oh my God.
Then he just drove off
for those kids.
That's probably one of the coolest things ever.
Yeah.
Joey Diaz,
man,
he was another one.
Like I,
when I,
when I first met him and I started hanging out with them.
Yeah.
You know,
I immediately we started,
we started working together.
I think Joey and I did sets in the nineties really for real.
We did like,
I think we did rascals in New York and New Jersey Rather.
I think we did that shit in there like the late nineties we started going on the
road together.
Like whenever he came to town,
whenever it was,
I was taking him on the road.
Him loved him.
I loved him.
I just knew that this guy,
I knew like if everybody could see this guy,
the way I see this guy like to me,
he's just,
he was just a joy.
That's cool.
He was just this guy who would come around and he would freak people out because
he was really big back then and he looked like a football player.
He was probably like 230 to 40 meters near that.
Well,
he was,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't even want to guess how cause Joe,
he's a big guy.
Joe,
he's about six foot tall and he's very wide.
You know,
he's got that thick,
like Cuban build.
He's a thick fucker.
Like before he was overweight,
crammed in like a Cuban sandwich in any dangerous air about him.
He was like a dangerous dude.
He had just left the life.
Yeah.
I mean,
he had been in prison just a few years prior and because I spent so much time
hanging around pools when I lived in New Jersey and New York rather,
I,
um,
I liked those guys.
You've got draws more from that.
Guys are fun.
Right?
They're fun guys to hang around with.
Those guys were laughing at shit and they were,
they were always the guys.
I mean,
there was always trouble.
Like,
you know,
I've,
I've been around Joey snapping,
not dudes and not where I was worried he might hit somebody with a bottle and
Joey gets fucking crazy.
I saw my friend Johnny,
my friend Johnny who reminds me of Joey.
I saw him hit this guy in the head,
a coffee mug.
Fuck his head up.
Really?
Yeah.
He grabbed a coffee,
but they got in some fight.
It was like,
oh,
it'd be around that kind of Shit,
man.
I'll be good to know where the guy,
like Joey was like,
he kept it together better than Johnny did.
Joey was Joey's smarter in some ways,
like socially or aware of,
you know how he's coming off?
Joey,
just,
you know,
he's just a wild motherfucker that lived a wild life,
but he's,
I knew that he was like this great guy,
you know?
I was like,
this guy's like,
sometimes he's so special,
like he's like one of my favorite human beings of all time because he's just so
genuinely him.
You know?
Joey's doesn't have any airs about him.
He's not,
he's not trying to pretend to be anybody and no,
you're right.
He totally is not trying to be anything else.
He figured out how to do it on stage.
Yeah.
He was always the best at that being the exact same offstage onstage.
He was the best of that where there was really no difference between those two
characters.
Yeah.
So we started going on the road together,
like right away when I heard he used to have a hard time for hauling him to man.
There's a bunch of times,
the beginning I realized like,
wow,
this is like,
it was like that thought,
this is good.
I got to ramp it up,
but I'm like,
man,
I can't half ass going on after this guy because he's so strong.
He's so strong.
He would go on these Lennar killer.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
People would tell me,
you know,
like what's wrong with you?
Like why are you taking Joe deals on the road with you?
Like do you want to follow that guy that would call him to teach people a lesson
in towns?
They would,
yeah,
we're going to have Joey future for warrior.
They did the fucking Kevin Meaney and Miami,
Kevin Meeney at the Miami Improv properties like this prick.
He's giving me a hard time.
I'm gonna fucking Book D is right in front of him.
The guy who ran the place was nuts and he was Joey's friend and they were all
doing the Colombian marching and powder together and they were they and they sat
that weekend up.
So Joey Diaz goes on into Cuban room.
Okay,
you're in Miami,
Cuba.
Half of his act,
he doesn't span.
Okay.
I'm not kidding.
I'm not fucking kidding.
And I mean,
he does his one man show in Spanish.
You could have lit everyone in that room on fire and kicked him in the balls and
they would still be laughing at them.
He was caught.
He was crushing in a way that's like biblical,
like you don't get to see that.
It's like these moments that happen,
they never get captured on film.
It's like a 10 o'clock show on a Friday night in Miami and he's crushing in the
room in a way where you,
you got to step out of the room for a while just to catch your breath.
You know,
you gotta watch it with the door half open so you could wheeze and breathe.
And then they through Kevin Meeney on after him,
just like,
fuck you pants people.
Yeah,
he's just the killing.
Yeah.
It's not in me.
He's a funny guy.
Funny Guy.
That's funny.
So back to my billboard.
So anyway,
I knew even way,
way,
way back then.
You know when you first started out.
Well,
I knew just talking to him,
I'm like,
this is a smart dude.
Smart Dude.
You're funny.
You're capable of making really good jokes sometimes.
Yeah.
Like all you have to do is just keep going.
I just knew that.
And so to be your friend through this whole thing and to see you from,
you know,
your baby steps
and stand up and trying to figure it out all the years he tried to get past the
store,
you know that opening to your podcast when you talked about your comedy central
special,
which is called pay regular,
which is I'm so it's so,
it's such a good special but it's so strong like what you did.
Um,
because for the longest time you see you weren't getting passive paid regular
biggest fucking hurdle.
I had to get over like a long time.
It was way easier for me.
I got in pretty quick because of the Todd [inaudible] and because I was already
headline you or came in as a,
as developed guy.
I started there.
I was,
you know,
I was still,
I sucked.
I was uh,
I had some shit.
I had some shit that would occasionally can,
I just hadn't figured out how to put it all together yet.
But the store is where I learned how to put it all together.
Oh really?
Yeah man.
Fuck Ya.
Yeah.
I learned dude going on after Martin Lawrence in the main room on a fucking
Saturday night when he was,
when he was doing what he was doing.
Those concert movies is in the moon,
man.
His shirt.
Yeah.
That one dude,
I followed leather,
the leather jumpsuit on.
I called him.
He can't even say I ate it because there's just was no reaction.
You know,
people,
Oh God,
it was just death.
That's the coolest thing.
It's like headline shows over like,
no,
there's going to be for more young comics on who are just learning how to do
comedy.
It's the worst environment.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess I ate it,
but eight is just not good enough.
Word ate it.
Like when you eat it,
you can eat it.
You can still kind of like half ass here.
There is way worse than ate it.
I ate,
I just,
I just breathing air and F is a 55,
58,
you know,
I've got a 12.
It's like,
it's beyond them.
I've done fucking brought it up there.
So,
um,
and I did that all the time.
I did that after dice.
I used to do that after anyone that was any good.
I did it after Damon Wayans.
I did it after.
That's what Mitzi would do.
She would just shove you on and I,
so I learned there and when you started coming up
I just saw,
I just knew it.
I'm like,
you could do it.
Yeah,
you'll come hang out with the employee time to you came to that time were all
the employees were do each other's jokes.
They'll like pick out of a hat.
You get this guys too.
It was fun.
It everyone did when you were like,
you were making fun of like certain people,
like I've never seen this material that I've seen it.
But you knew the other guys doing it.
Like you came from the employee time a lot.
Yeah.
Well it's like I said,
you know,
we all think this dao,
we all sort of share this,
this idea now that we're all just comics,
you know?
And that's the beautiful thing about the store is that this is fraternity where
there's guys that are part of it that are really just starting out.
Man.
And there's other guys that had been around it for like Russell,
that people thing that the story of these door guys who were like a lot of
people that are like major professionals that we're all so door guys there were
work,
the booth worked the phone.
So it's not like,
excuse me employee.
It's like,
oh,
excuse me,
someone who was just like this friend of mine,
copper Roulo was a door.
I was a door guy.
Run as easy,
you know from the league.
These are people that like started fucking mopping on vomit.
Yeah.
So then when you see the new guys mopping up vomit and I see them now fucking
around with don bears late at night and really growing for the first time.
Do we pass this kid on the way back?
Who was with us?
Did you know?
Oh,
red band.
We were coming back from uh,
the standard.
We've read man and Pete and this guy just left the store and I was laying eggs.
I saw boobs.
Like what?
Like the girl took her boobs out.
I felt him
where it's like just now was in the back and he got this girl and then I
remember like it's the degenerating of these,
it's sort of once you start with like as a beautiful pure kid,
you let,
you're met with this awful degeneracy like w who are these people?
What are they doing?
The drugs and the fucking and the different like depravity did site and then you
just get changed.
I remember some waitress may,
some really beautiful like Latino veal fin and like real pure look.
And I was sitting the,
the uh,
the open mic,
her's and someone was yelling.
I was like,
shut the fuck up or I'll kick you out.
No more warnings.
And She just goes,
you've changed.
And it does change is all from this kid.
It never felt a boob before.
The idea that he could feel some tea girl's tits,
what people are watching and laughing.
So it just,
it makes you a comic to darkness in the room.
Yeah.
Dragged you into it.
It's dry as hell.
It invites you in and then says,
I'll give you the option.
Do you want to take the pill?
Do you want to leave?
Well,
it also liked,
I think there's echoes of the 80s with Sam Kinison did to that place back in the
crazy wild coke days when he was the number one comic in the world.
And you know,
anybody would come to see shows and we do these midnight spots and you know
those days like that craziness of that time,
all those crazy fucked up people on their drugs.
The Echo's,
we're still like running through that building.
Yeah,
you're right.
People are still like returning and then it would be getting more people
returning.
That's just an excuse to use the word,
but yet
it has the right time.
Right time to throw it out there.
First Time I heard but get,
oh sorry,
go ahead.
No,
it's not been good at some begins
in begins is from,
it's from the sentence anyway,
go ahead.
So you went through this long development period,
you did it mostly at the store and then on the road,
you know,
and we would do gigs together.
Yeah,
it was,
you saw the whole thing though.
I mean from the beginning,
that road stuff was super instrumental.
Being able to spread my wings and be like,
oh,
okay,
here's what it is.
Here's what I've been learning for.
It's not just sparring.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's something I never got from anybody else.
No,
I never really had that opportunity to have some helpful with me.
And you can see what better comedy is on a night to night basis and see beyond
just what your jokes are than how you're doing.
Um,
and you know,
when you go after a Heckler,
when you don't,
and that was the best thing about learning at the store too.
You see these great comics,
you see Paul Mooney command a stage and you're like,
oh,
how does he do that?
You don't get to just watch once you get to watch 45 times in three months and
you start to understand it to work.
They're like,
you did.
It's an unbelievable education.
I mean,
that's what happened with Eleanor [inaudible],
Eleanor Kerrigan,
our friend who was a waitress there forever.
She wasn't a comic,
but she was hilarious and she was also a great judge of talent.
Like if some dude was in from out of town and I would go,
how is it?
And she'd be like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Heck she would go like,
she would nail it,
you know,
she would go,
he's fucking funny.
You gotta Watch this guy's fucking funny.
And if Alan were told me that I was sitting down right,
I'm like,
great,
this guy's going to be really good luck too.
It's up.
Yeah.
She would call like managers and agents tell them like they had this person for
real.
She's awesome.
So nice to see her doing stand up.
But so you were,
you went through all this struggle and then over the last few years,
everything is fucking taken off.
You have a comedy central specials.
You sold your last special condoms.
There's this Friday is this Friday at midnight on comedy central?
Midnight Eastern,
I think 11 and 10 other times though,
and you can buy it right now,
there's a banner should be up really soon.
Right route or the great.com you can get it for pay what I'm doing.
Pay What you want.
Pay What the good songs y'all do with dollar.
That's cool.
Their system,
but fuck it.
I love it.
Yeah.
So all this has happened over the last few years and you get this comedy
central,
the show that you're on the show,
the homeowner's Day,
Thursday night.
This is not happening.
And there's a billboard and does not.
Ari's idea he didn't ask for this.
There's a billboard above his old fucking apartment and the billboard above your
old fucking parlor is that this is not happening with you,
bro.
Fun.
I have picture of me.
Fuck an eagle.
Yeah,
this is America.
W w what you are in that picture on my Instagram.
Look at that picture because you can see them and you can see the window of my
old,
of my old apartment.
Look at that picture.
That's one of my favorite pictures of all time.
Look at that fucking picture,
man.
You're so happy you did it.
That is,
that's officially you did it was that last night anyway.
Oh,
I mean if you go off the wall crazy and uh,
jump off a fucking building.
I had a billboard in my,
yeah,
it's pretty,
I don't know.
I've gotten so much.
People are so much more excited about this.
Then the show or the special will,
the show's awesome.
You know,
shows awesome.
It's great.
But there's something so nutty about the visual of that billboard above her old
apartment.
The fact that it's right there is so god damn crazy.
That's your fucking apartment.
Look at that.
Where my head is sticking out.
That's mine.
That's my bedroom window.
This is insane.
This is like some real weird simulation shit
that's so fucking weird.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
You wouldn't see in a movie.
You'd be like,
no fucking way.
I've never been happier for someone else likes that.
Then this happen to you.
I've never been happier.
It's,
it's amazing to see,
dude.
It's so cool.
It's so fucking cool.
It's wild.
Does that,
that doesn't even seem like,
like again,
if that was in a movie,
you'd be like,
come on.
They put a fucking billboard right next to me.
You'd be like,
no.
Hey Man.
Come on.
Make it down the street.
That would still be something.
Yeah.
And it would be like a conspiracy theory.
Oh he fucking course he told them he wanted the billboard above his old
apartment.
It's,
it's the comedy central bill.
But they bought it like five years ago and they've been putting stuff up there
by the way,
you lived there way before that before that.
Exactly that.
But man it sucked.
Also walk under it going like fuck,
I'll show billboard.
I wish I could get one one day.
That's hard man.
But listen,
everyone's listening right now.
Set Your dvrs were 12th.
There's two episodes left of that is not happening.
1230 on Thursday nights.
Rogan's on this one and you can see as big fun youtube right now and set your
DVR for um,
passive aggressive on Friday at midnight because if everybody watched it and
dvrs is the first time they've run it a bunch of more.
So that first time is really important.
How much did they know about dvrs and get the info,
the info when people recording.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So all you freaks out there,
weird shit on your DVR.
They're playing my other one a lot more now cause everybody fucking washed it.
Thank you guys for fucking watching and Dvr it.
Yeah.
Oh that looks at the first one comes in.
Hmm.
Then they're super happy with it.
So wonder if you have someone you DVR and you play it more than once.
If they know you're playing it more than once.
So I don't know if it means that if you went to watch it for them to register or
just DVR it.
Yeah.
Right.
Everyone right now help me out.
Just DVR both those things right now.
What if we found out that if you teach DVR and watch it,
the Dutch just runs up the number and then we get these Chinese people would
have like watch all day.
Yeah,
you just have,
you know,
it just gigantic rooms would be help for them because they wouldn't know what it
meant dvrs and just kept telling him to keep pressure.
Pete press play and you just giant Bank of people making like 5 cents an hour.
All these trying to shave off like,
you know,
we can program something for you.
Like no,
shut up.
Mining DVR hits
already should fear the number one television show.
Human history.
Everyone with the DVR watches it.
They scientifically shown like why?
Yeah,
just keep it.
Yeah.
Run his diet factory orange bears sweatshop.
I wonder how it works.
Um,
so I didn't know if they knew how to check.
If people do get the numbers like a few days,
I get the first numbers and they get the second number is what are the numbers
like for like satellite TV.
Can they tell how many people were watching what shows?
And when people have an issue with that,
right?
People don't want to get labeled.
They don't want,
yeah.
So I watch Fox News 23 hours a day.
It doesn't mean I want to kill the president.
Right.
They don't get labeled.
But here's the problem.
So I,
I fucking signed into my,
saw something through a server or something and my youtube thinks I'm Mexican.
Now what?
Yeah,
all the commercials are in Spanish.
It's always offering me fucking taco pickup trucks,
Taco,
all that shit,
bro.
It totally dance about not,
not like a jokey things,
not Spanish.
It thinks I live in Mexico.
Why or Spain or something.
It's only given me fucking Spanish commercials.
There's probably a preference settings.
[inaudible] made I Saturday night.
I'm getting ads for that all the time after this is over young Jamie,
we'll sort that.
Yeah,
maybe we've got a log around.
He'll find out what the fuck is up with it.
I'm sure there's something.
You just missed your stone stupor.
It's been cool though,
man.
People show up to my shows now and they're like,
I saw the show or I saw your stand up instead of like,
you know,
and it's nice to,
people know me from podcasts or the amazing race was nice too,
but it's like,
that's like,
oh,
that's what I do.
That's what I want you to see me from.
Yeah.
From my stand up from preparing and developing material and they like it.
They just had to know that's a,
that's a big thing that's going on right now.
It's like you just have to know about someone.
Like sometimes people look get the chance to watch.
Yeah.
So this is really funny guys.
You just don't know about it.
But if people knew about him,
it's not that the product's not there,
it's just the delight.
It's awkward to figure out the delivery device.
You remember the first time when you were 14 year old,
the first time you like you found out about siren.
I live and you were like,
cause it's made for 14 to 23 year olds.
But at the time it was really great and you're like,
I didn't know TV could be this funny this out.
They're like,
this is amazing.
But it was just as good the week before you knew about it.
You just hadn't been made aware.
Right.
And it's this thing you would've loved if you just gave us a chance or just
turned it on.
Or just had your mom be out of town so he can stay up late.
Like you find it in about a new band or something and then you go back and
listen to the old stuff.
Yeah.
There's always going to be something like that.
So always,
but that's with stand up comedy,
you know,
I think it's kind of important for everybody that's involved in it to like keep
helping and supporting young comics.
Keep,
keep encouraging young comics because one of the reasons why standup is in like
a really good place right now is a lot of people that go to comedy clubs and
shows her being real successful.
It's because there's so many funny guys.
Right.
That's what it is.
It's not that you don't,
you don't want to be the only one person doing it.
No.
You want me to get a full good show?
Well you also want a giant industry.
You want to a giant more people go sit calmly.
They enjoy it.
It's fun for us.
Look here at top.
Never hurt comedy.
No carrot top is not my,
although I'll be honest,
the carrot top is my taste.
It's so fucking silly and dumb.
It's funny.
Yeah,
I don't mind that at all,
but whenever we're shooting on carrot top,
it least it means people are going out to comedy and they're like,
oh,
stand up is funny.
And then maybe they'll discover this stuff that really into way more specific to
where maybe that's like their speed they liked on talking with those to yeah,
I think that uh,
it's super important that we is encouraged more people do it as much as positive
women,
regulars or clubs now on the road to people that go like four or five,
10 times a year or two to a comedy club where it's,
it's a good day and it's a bit,
it's like a movie and it's better,
more real than a movie.
If you go see Sikora Dina and full Toronto,
me and you and you know,
if you know that someone that you really think is funny,
he's going to be in town.
This is going to be a great time.
I used to get my friend from DC,
Avi Lerner,
he used to ask me DC Improv lineup.
He'd look at him like,
is there anybody I should see?
I shouldn't see like he was like,
it's time to go out to it to a good date,
you know,
until you'd be like,
oh,
avoid that guy.
He's super hacky.
I don't know these two.
And that guy is actually pretty good.
And he's like,
cool.
Yeah.
You just want to know who the good ones are.
That's the thing,
because we all know once you're stuck listening to some crazy contrived like,
oh,
I gotta get Outta here.
Or like if you're not into those hypnotists and you go to the hypnotist week and
you're like,
fuck,
why did I go to this?
Yeah.
I just think it's one of those art forms that needs a help from the people that
do it.
And I think the more the people that do it help,
the more more people do it.
Like,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm meeting dudes on the road all the time now that started doing open mic
nights.
Weird huck cast.
Yeah.
That's why it's so weird when Dane Cook says people like comics stole his
essence and it's like,
Oh Dang,
you were super influential.
Comic Book.
Steven Wright was the same way.
You like,
you brought physical comedy into the mainstream where people started doing it
more.
Bob Nelson was the last big physical comic.
I don't know that all these guys were watching comedy when they were 1415 years
old and now it's been 10 12 years and they're doing comedy and you're one of the
guys they watch coming up.
Yeah.
So it's like,
yeah,
of course they got into it because of you.
You can't,
and you want Jim Carey.
Yeah.
You watched him caring.
So it's like you can't,
you everyone,
you know,
there's that weird line when someone is influenced and when someone is
imitating.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's the weird line.
Yeah.
It's like we're all influencing each other and we're all influenced by prior.
Everyone should,
for once by Ozzy said he was influenced by the Beatles.
Yeah.
And when you look at that,
you're like,
no way.
But you're like,
there's something in there.
They're probably,
you know,
that you can't,
it's not a straight copy.
So you wouldn't think that.
Yeah.
I mean,
it doesn't have to be a copy.
Influence means it's moves you in a certain way.
I'm influenced by music.
A lot of songs influenced me that they don't influence my,
my words,
they don't influence my comedy,
but they influenced my thinking positions the way they handle it to live music.
Yeah.
Wait a musician.
That's why I do it.
Different tour should every year because iron maiden,
Oh shit I made did that and I was like,
interesting.
I liked the way they,
they way they close strong,
you know,
you can see that fucking,
I dunno the way that you know,
certain great bands.
You're like,
oh,
that was a good concert.
Yeah.
I want to mimic that.
Fuck yeah man.
The few times that have gone to see a honey honey live.
Yeah.
Like I love watching talent like Ben and Suzanne from honey,
honey.
There's so God damn talented.
So,
and her voice is just ridiculously good.
I think that going to be at some festival and plying.
Yeah,
they were there in town.
Right now we're bouncing phone calls back and forth to each other.
I've got to get to get together with those guys.
They're really nice and they're just stupid talented in a way that I don't
understand.
Like I don't understand like music talent.
Yeah.
I can't sing.
So when I hear someone singing I'm like,
whoa,
that was crazy and I want you to what you want with her fois.
Oh yeah.
But also what makes someone command a stage.
Like you can have like muse has this giant light show and everything.
It's that I get,
you know,
um,
flaming lips has all this confetti and shit and then I get,
but if it's just the people that are just playing the music and some kill it and
some don't,
it's like,
what's the difference?
Yeah.
Has Been Nico Vega and we saw it hurt during the sunset shift festival once and
it was like,
oh my gosh,
she's playing one of the,
they were playing one of the inside sales agents that have won a giant wants and
it's like she's blown it out of the water and it's like,
how,
what are they doing?
Just jumping up around a lot,
like half of it.
All you gotta do is really love what you're doing.
Yeah.
There's definitely,
that's a big part of smashing pumpkins or garbage.
Now Billy Corgan is the only one left in the band.
He hires an Asian basis to look like Jimmy [inaudible] or whatever his name is,
a female guitarists to look like the old and then they just play all the old
songs at double speed cause he fucking hates them now.
Wow.
He plays only as new stuff.
Regular speed.
He changed his lyrics.
He's all Jesus out now.
Well that's got,
it's empty just like you.
Really.
Yeah.
What happened?
He cleared out the fucking in Columbus.
He cleared that place.
He was headlining a festival day.
Bush killed it during the day.
It ain't about being old and then people just,
by the time I was like,
all right,
we can leave.
It was half empty.
The place.
Courtney love Courtney love rectum ruined them.
I don't know.
He just doesn't want to play his music.
He didn't want that Super Pussy.
Got To love what you're doing.
You know what super policy.
Yeah.
She might to put these stolen Saudi love must've been.
Of course she's probably still is.
People.
Scott Sprung over her dude.
I'll tell you what,
man,
I don't know what influence he had over those whole songs,
but some of those songs were fucking good.
Ballparks was amazing.
Yes.
Our next album after that,
after the mountain doll parts,
which is piece of me,
I forget,
but the next one after that about the stolen raw water of la or whatever it was,
that was a good album,
and I think that might've been the Billy Corgan album.
I don't know,
man,
who,
whoever the fuck was involved,
they had some really good fucking songs.
Right?
Doesn't matter where she got it from.
She got it still,
whatever,
whoever,
whatever the collaboration was,
but he was involved in some point in time.
It's sad to see that he's losing his fucking marvels.
I was trying to get her from my storyteller show.
Whoa,
we want to put a musician on it.
That wouldn't be bad.
I bet you'd have a good story or two.
Yeah,
for sure.
If going nuts or 20 or 20 people that accused her,
they were make documentaries accusing her of killing her husband.
Imagine that.
Imagine if your husband committed suicide and there's people making
documentaries and he to kill you of killing him when you know you didn't kill
him.
Imagine going through life like that.
Yeah.
Some of the wacky conspiracy shut up already.
I've said how it's I was somewhere else,
you know,
or could you imagine if she killed him?
Him.
That's it.
Everybody.
Thanks.
Come on doing it too
know,
but fuck man.
To accuse someone of something like that.
It's so I heard a horrible loss.
Drops his baby and that sent him like he was already depressed and heroin doubt
and then dropping her baby on heroin.
Is it?
Oh,
I'm a piece of shit.
Oh my God.
Then it just like blew up.
Blew it off.
Oh my God.
That sounds like a good story.
That's like one of those headless Horseman Type Story.
I heard
he was alone.
If it's midnight in October and you look up and it's a full moon,
you'll see the headless horseman.
It's true brown.
My uncle saw it,
bro.
We,
we're in Utah.
We talked to these guys that told us that they saw you bulletproof wolf that
appeared out of missed really [inaudible] guys had shot at it and that's how
they knew it was bulletproof cause they always had these mother fuckers are
shooting at imaginary wolves in the middle of Utah.
How good is their math?
Wow.
That's,
wow.
That was just know I have some strong math along with some loneliness.
Here's wanted,
know what meth feels like,
what heroin feels like.
Yeah,
go ahead and coke.
I wanna I want to know what all that shit feels like.
Yeah.
I just don't want to do it and have the ill effects of it.
I'm not interested in opiates for sure.
For sure.
That's the one that takes a fry Yom and an opium den.
Oh,
John Wayne or no,
it wasn't John Wayne through uh,
one of those fucking outlaws.
Like wild bill Hitchcock or something like killing an opium den.
You didn't,
well,
he just fucked him up.
He became an opium addict.
Was it him or was it,
um,
who is the guy,
Kevin Wider I think later.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think I've heard that.
Yeah.
I think a lot of the doc holiday was a dentist who gave him the opium.
Oh my goodness.
A lot of those dudes would like our visit.
Those,
they had Chinese,
the Chinese people who,
uh,
helped build the railroads are basically built the railroads.
Really,
man,
you still a bunch of gold.
You've got a bunch of gold.
Of course you can get into drugs.
He's 11:00 PM dens.
They probably wouldn't even illegal back then.
They probably were not illegal.
Yeah,
probably people didn't have like the kind of laws they have now because we've
got wild west palm wasn't illegal until the 1930s and psychedelics weren't
illegal until 1970 and they used to give cocaine like you were used to being
coca cola.
Yeah.
Can you imagine if you,
if you've come across some native Americans,
you're not in the wild west,
you know,
we're talking about 18,
10 or something and you come around and they're not,
they're not violent.
They're,
they take you in and they take care of their,
their tent and they want to show you their ways and they feed you.
And they keep you this pipe and you're like,
oh that's,
that's this,
this is crazy.
That's the peace pipe.
That's not the crazy,
the smell shit in it.
Yeah.
Can you imagine,
are there cups around,
you know,
is there a sheriff here?
Cause he's going to throw me in jail for this.
I don't think they smoked opium.
I think the peace pipe was that was a backhoe.
Oh really?
Just tobacco.
That was marijuana.
I don't think so man.
When did,
where her want to start?
I think marijuana.
I don't,
I mean they probably use it if they knew about it,
if they had found it,
but I think they use tobacco a lot as well.
Wild tobacco.
I think that will get you high.
Yeah.
Tobacco gets you in a weird way.
I mean that's why guys like smoking cigars.
Find out what the fuck
is in the peace pipe there,
Jamie.
It's gotta be,
uh,
some answers,
but I don't think it's helped me smoke them to peace pipe.
No,
I don't think it was [inaudible] or marijuana cause opiums not grown in the
United States.
I don't think you can.
I think it's gotta be like South America.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't think you can grow it here.
I think he grow in Afghanistan and I think you can grow it in some climates and
South America or something like that.
I've heard,
I have no idea what it is.
It's one of those things like,
like how the fuck can they not grow cocaine?
The United States,
they keep saying they import cocaine.
Yeah.
I said,
wait,
wait.
We,
we have these hydroponic
grow it here.
It's like there's not plants that don't grow in certain geographic locations are
there?
Yeah.
But then you could grow them inside when you did,
you could manipulate the environment to simulate like a South American rain
forest.
We just wouldn't be as good.
Like,
like grapes need to be on,
uh,
on,
have the sun hitting in most of the days they need to be on like an incline.
Oh really?
What does that Kinda connects?
Just the plant native American smoking product typically made it a mixture of
various leaves or barks with other plant materials.
Whoa.
So they just work.
So it was just bark and shit.
Wow.
Hmm.
Okay.
Tobacco.
So they did some eastern tribes.
It wasn't dropped off from mixed it with other herbs.
Barks and plant matter and a preparation,
commonly known as [inaudible].
Cuny kick knee.
Okay.
Can any,
Niki,
can nick,
can Nate to keep means Kinnikinnik.
It means whole of our fathers.
It means we smoke bark.
It's one of the only impressions I can do and I'm sure all the and is listening.
You're like,
that's terrible.
Well,
it's just crazy.
We still call them Indians.
It's like the dumbest shit of all time because they're not can landed in here
once you know there's still nine.
That's why it's dob.
You're right.
A lot of thoughts of it.
Back to the people using it.
It's offensive to all of us.
Defensive to me,
I grew up playing cowboys and Indians.
I didn't know it was,
you know,
saying something really fucking stupid
to not Indian.
This is native American.
It was just somebody thought it was somewhere else.
There are real Americans.
He'd call,
I'm going to call them native Americans.
I guess it was native native.
I like native in America.
There was a bunch of disputes about why America was named America,
but what I had heard ago Vespucci yeah,
that's what I had heard growing up.
Wow.
Fuck yeah.
High school left when they're on it's time.
That's what I had heard growing up,
but I didn't even know who the fuck America Vespucci was until I like,
why is this guy,
I thought Christopher Columbus discovered America.
Who was the miracle?
Vespucci I was fucking jackass who snuck in and change the whole fucking name.
Wait a minute,
let us here.
America was named after America.
Vespucci do,
did you do 15th century Florentine Merchant who owned a business in Seville,
Spain.
Furnishing supplies for ships,
preparing them for merchants Heil.
Oh,
so he didn't even discover it.
He's just like supplied Columbus with it.
So it really,
that is absolutely really what it was.
So the shit that we learned in high school was true,
but why not call it a mirror ago?
Yeah,
it was just weird.
How about you talk to someone who already lived here?
Yeah,
you guys call it.
But that's like somebody names a country after me and calls it aura.
Right.
It's like fucking name enough to me then bro.
Yeah.
Why are you calling it a miracle land?
American lands good.
We're a miracle and fuck.
Yeah,
it doesn't look the same.
Why America?
Cause it sounds right.
Mariko America sounds fine.
America.
You ever seen when people get really down on America,
they write the k with a k like,
like instead of ca and taken away our rights.
She was like,
no.
Cause it's like KKK Co really?
In America.
It's the federalist is Soviet Nazi fucking feeling to it.
Right.
Just see Rick Ross run over that guy.
Not Rick wrote his name.
Ah,
shook night.
Chuck Knight.
The video's out.
You watched it?
No,
not yet.
He ran over the guy's head.
Right?
Jamie show.
Oh Jamie,
please.
Oh my God,
I do that.
I don't want to see this.
You're right as a human,
but we're going to watch it.
Oh,
but it's not playing on TV.
Right.
All right,
go ahead.
Fuck Dude,
this is something I'm not really interested in.
So what did he,
what did he do?
It was over a fight.
[inaudible] truck.
I'll do the idea.
Z Jane Boone.
Oh my God.
I think he showed up there filming the Nwa movie.
Oh,
the whole thing shook.
He wasn't invited.
The whole thing shook when bone got over there.
The whole car.
So like he shook them or they shoot the Yang.
Yell at each other.
I don't think any shots were fired.
No,
just get run over here.
Oh my God.
No Way.
Terry.
That's the guy who died.
Oh,
oh no.
he ran them over.
Oh my God.
Wow.
He pulled out random movement.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
It's just the,
Oh my God.
Wow.
Did they released it today so that people stopped like third party accounts stop
happening.
People say,
Oh my God.
Oh Wow.
That's so hard to watch.
Wow.
Thanks for forced me to watch that.
You Fuck Jesus Christ.
So happens you don't get repercussions start then you can do whatever the fuck
you want to.
Who was that?
Who ran him over night?
Wow.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean that guy just got killed,
killed,
run over like by the head and then run over again.
Two of them hit two.
We ran over two guys.
Yep.
The second guy is the guy that died.
Guy Did not stop.
He ran that guy over twice with a truck.
That's so insane.
Man.
Oof.
Jesus Christ.
You can get away with murder.
Do you think you would do it ever?
You?
Only time you would ever do it as if like you were,
someone was trying to attack you or someone's trying to attack someone that you
love fits of rage?
No.
No jealousy.
No,
never.
That's why,
and that's why in that movie,
remember when they could tell the future and see who was going to kill,
what was that called?
Minority report.
The only one they couldn't catch where it fits of rage because they weren't
planned at all.
Right,
right.
That makes sense.
Thinking clearly,
that makes guys,
that's my red truck.
I got to run him over when I was a little kid.
I saw a lot of violence and it was very,
it was very uncomfortable.
So I a lot of like domestic abuse violence,
so I'm the last person that could ever get involved in that kind of shit.
I just,
I'm not interested in fighting,
especially with somebody that I care about.
I'm not interested in that.
I'm saying I'm saying you get away with it.
I wouldn't do it.
It just,
that's not an option.
The only reason why I would do it as if someone was trying to attack me,
right?
Like I wouldn't be the person that attacked them.
The only way I would ever attack someone is if I thought that my life was in
danger or my health was in danger or someone else's health or life was in
danger.
I would never just hit somebody cause I was mad at him.
Right.
I mean murder them,
erase them.
Any of those things I to do that,
I would've already done it if I,
if that was my path,
if I was on that path,
even if it was free and legal and you'd get away with it,
it wouldn't just who you are as a person changes who you are as a person.
If you're eliminating people.
If you're,
you're harming you go.
And after people got,
some people say,
I would never be able to live with myself and I that I disagree with for
everybody because everyone who does it lives with themselves.
Okay,
well let's say this Ted Bundy,
but if you found Ted Bundy would have Ted Bundy,
uh,
did that to someone that you knew and killed book.
No,
I felt terrible.
And you had a chance to catch him in the act yet.
Catch him as he was trying to abduct a woman.
You knew it was Ted Bundy and I could,
I wish I would end that motherfucker so easy.
He would do that.
Oh yeah,
100%.
If I saw Ted Bundy,
like trying to drag a woman,
and I knew it was Ted Bundy.
Yeah,
100% I'd kill him.
He's in jail,
right?
Percent.
He's dead.
They killed him.
But I would have killed him.
You would've shore.
That's a guy that I won't even think twice if I had a gun and shoot him fed
knife out at stake.
It wasn't about to do something.
But you knew Ted Bundy.
I probably still kill them.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but do you probably do something again though?
I would probably,
I'd probably confront him and then he would give me a reason to think that he
was dangerous and then I would,
I would try to kill him.
Confront.
Yeah.
If you,
if you knew that some guy was,
if you,
if he got away from you,
he was,
he's addicted to killing women.
He wouldn't kill that guy if you know for sure it's that guy.
Right.
That's the problem.
Cosby.
We're just stops them from doing that.
Yeah.
I mean if you caught him,
oh my God,
what would you do if you caught a guy?
If you need to stop doing this?
I can't man,
because I,
that's the only time I can get hard as it,
so I can't stop.
So what are you going to do now?
Could you imagine that conversation?
I mean,
let's say we're not even talking
about,
don't even say it's bill Cosby.
Let's just assume it was someone else.
Okay.
Forget what good's not attach him.
[inaudible] he did or didn't do it.
I'm but some white guy,
some white guy.
So some random person,
if you walked in and some random person had drugged a woman and was busy fucking
her body and she didn't even,
you know,
probably didn't,
not only did barely knew the guy,
he just,
no,
I mean it's already happening.
No,
he should stop now.
It would probably be so dangerous to confront it.
Like the kind of person that's willing to do that.
This is where it gets dark,
you know,
whether it's a guy we were talking about before,
that comedian fellow or anybody else,
some random person to type of person that has the mindset to want to put you in
an intoxicated state,
like a dud,
a drug state.
So you don't know what happened.
You wake up and you're like,
why am I naked?
Like what's going on?
And he thinks that's funny or he thinks that's acceptable.
Or he can live with that and he can do it again and again and again.
Like he's done it many,
many times before.
There's a dehumanizing effect of that.
That's terrifying.
It's not not just sexual.
There's a De humanizing thing of you deciding to shut someone's consciousness
off.
And then do what you would with with the routes.
So crazy dude.
It is beyond creepy.
It is terrifying.
So how do you get that?
You get that as your affliction that you need to do that.
You would have to talk to someone far smarter than me and I could speculate all
day and I'm sure have,
remember that one guy in that show,
whatever.
That's what they call child molesters.
Yeah.
Oh the catch a predator.
But one guy was so resigned,
I could tell he was so resigned to that.
Him being this way that he was like,
once he came out,
it's like,
do you know where we're here?
Is like,
oh,
he goes,
just get the cops so they can lock me up and execute me already.
Like he was talking about like that he couldn't change and I know he couldn't
change,
so we needed someone to catch up.
Can it be stopped?
He knew it.
So terrifying.
It's terrifying.
And the fact that you'll talk to women and they'll tell you that they've been
drugged.
Oh,
like I've talked a bunch of different girls,
a bit of an drug.
Do you know you'll,
you'll hear them talking about it or you'll be talking about it and someone will
come over.
That happened to me.
Did you hear a talking to Larry King?
No.
Jeremy's talking to Larry.
Larry King recently.
No,
a long time ago about Spanish law.
Yes,
I did hear that.
Yeah,
that was disturbing.
Now looking back,
it's so disturbing.
And Larry King's trying to giggle along like he's like,
I don't want to fuck up the interview,
but like what he's talking about giving them drugs that make them horny.
Yeah.
Against her will finish fly.
Listen,
don't dose people.
That's just a standard rule.
But Joey Diaz is dose people and I've let them take whatever was Joey Diaz now
with these stars that are a hundred and hundred milligrams or 125 so I'm like,
how much are they for real?
He goes,
yeah,
it's not,
it's like,
it's like 50 25 and 50 and I was like,
really?
So I get there and I see it's a 25 is like,
okay,
but something's fishy.
Just like these bill Cosby people,
they knew something was up.
These girls like,
wait,
what do you have a Cappuccino machine in your bedroom?
What's left?
Hold on.
And they knew something was up but they couldn't stop it.
And Joey d is something that looked fishing on a label on.
I asked him later,
I'm like,
what's up with that later?
I just took other labels and put it over the fucking hundred 25 milligram label
and I ate two of those motherfuckers.
He dosed you does everybody.
Why did he do that?
He thought it'd be funny.
Then he was right.
He was right.
He knows that he knew I could handle it whether or not I needed to or not.
So he wasn't intent on raping,
you know?
And he did let you know that you're going to be taking a marijuana.
I just didn't let you know that it was way stronger than it really is.
The best.
Alex Jones,
when he was like giving him a cookie at one of those dfcs and Alex Jones like
what's in his cooking?
Because you don't,
what the fuck is not going to eat the fucking cookie?
It's like mad.
Like,
how do you stop holding his fucking Hunky?
Come on.
Come on,
man.
That was a fun weekend.
That was part good.
Alex Jones all weekend at a UFC came to the comedy show.
He came and hung out.
Vegas.
Was that?
Yeah,
he's been to a bunch of comedy shows.
He was at my most recent.
That was cool as shit.
See If someones says thank you again for those.
Oh,
the right behind ringside.
Seen him smile and big smile on his face.
Extra frosty.
Yeah.
That's great man.
Sitting back there.
It's amazing.
So fun.
That place is awesome.
Even if it is just girl fights.
This girl fights.
He says,
I'm not interested,
not interested in girls fighting until she loses around.
Then it's just an exhibition.
I like it.
I liked that excavation.
Yeah,
it's cool.
It's fun.
You know what man?
She's like this in this Roy Jones Jr in his prime state.
Yeah.
Roy Jones Jr in his prime was just fucking everybody up.
He's putting his hands behind his back and knocking dudes out,
knocking guys like Virgil hill out with a body shot.
And while everybody,
everybody's like,
God Damn Roy Jones,
you know who's Virgil Hill?
Who see the guy who took care of macho man,
Randy Savage,
he was a million dollar man.
That's,
it's in virtually MP gold medalist,
but I believe he was an Olympic boxer and he was also a,
um,
uh,
a light heavyweight champion.
And uh,
yeah,
this is,
um,
yeah.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
I believe it was Virgil Hill.
He fought a Roy Jones and Roy Jones hit him with this fucking body shot that was
just ridiculous.
Wow.
Really cracked him to the body.
You see them just crumble on a body shot.
Yeah,
he was a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
He won a silver medal in the Olympic Games in 1984,
but Olympic box is always super thin.
Right.
That was heavy weights aren't heavyweights.
No.
I mean,
look,
cause there's youngest was an Olympian.
A British was the Olympian.
They were big guys,
but then they get picked or later.
Here's the,
here's Roy Jones Jr fighting Virgil.
And Virgil was like real high level fighter at the time.
Man Who's a world champion with hurdles in the black pants.
Boom.
Look at this body shot.
Oh he holds it son.
Yo hardest knock a guy out on the left side of his body.
Okay.
That's what,
that's what he hit him with a right hand to the body.
Usually it's a left and the reason being is not,
not usually,
but it's hard to knock a guy out with a right hand because like floating rib he
got him in the floating around.
He probably broke his rib.
It's usually on the left side because the left side is where the liver is so
weird for someone to go down like none ever watching UFC cause I'm going to go
down like that and then no one jumping on him.
Yeah,
exactly right.
It just seems so strange.
He's holding his side and you're like the why is this fight still going in the
fight when you always see dudes throwing left hook to the body.
Cause from the left side,
like if you're attacking that,
that side of the body that you're going to hit,
which is his right side is where the liver is.
So Roy Jones knocked him out with a body shot on the opposite side that you
usually usually getting either in the solar plexus or the liver,
but he hits so goddamn hard.
He was so fast.
But the point is like that's where Rhonda is a right above fucking everybody up.
She's just fucking everybody up and matter of fact decent.
Oh No.
It's like when I see,
when I saw Anderson in his prime,
when people call him the greatest of all time,
but his primary is fucking up guys that were like,
I could see winning a title if not for him.
Right.
Like rich Franklin.
Rich Franklin was was world champion yanked him out.
Yeah.
So it's like,
I don't know,
when I see the 11th ranked fighter in the world five and five it's like what
we're talking about here.
Well it took now Rhonda,
but to take away from the rest of the fucking way class.
It's a growing sport.
Yeah,
it's MMA is like men's MMA in 2000 or maybe even before then.
You know it's still growing.
I mean the UFC was started in [inaudible] 94 it became mainstream in like 2000
that'll be good for like girls training now.
Oh yeah.
They'll like the 16 year olds.
Like you know what I want to do MMA and then eight years there'll be legitimate
contenders for titles.
Yeah.
But like setting it up for later fucking star wars episode one.
But it's interesting man,
because she's not going to keep going forever.
There's going to,
someone's going to come along like they always come along.
Like someone came along with her eventually 10 years fighting into her thirties
for sure.
Right now she's in her prime,
but if she keeps fighting,
you know,
if Cyborg can figure out a way to get down on one 35 that could be from fucking
interesting.
But she,
she showed a photo of herself the other day on a scale and she said one 75 yeah,
like a couple of days after her fight.
One 75 that's what I should way.
Yeah,
I don't,
what are you talking about?
I mean,
I don't know if that's like to try to get people to be sympathetic about the
fact that if you want to get that fight with Ronda,
make fight at 45 but can get the fuck out of here with that one 75 yeah,
policy.
I bet she's probably all five.
Eight.
Jesus.
Yeah.
When I'm one 75 I'm in the middle of my BMI.
I'm like where I should be.
Not Thin or big at six three yeah.
She is a thick woman.
Let me see how tall she is.
Five.
Eight.
Yeah.
She's five.
Eight.
Yup.
See there's her 75 one 75 God,
her toes look tough.
Fucking bruised up.
Let's go to lunch.
Somebody lifts in Chicago in the winter.
They get all the things you should look
at the right foot with a scar.
That's probably from some of his fucking teeth.
Oh yeah.
She's probably kicked someone's teeth in with that foot.
She's,
she's bad ass man.
Say what you will about or prior substance use.
I'm just talking about those fucking fee.
The finished product of a Chris I born Jesus written on the side of him.
Is that what it says?
I Dunno.
Something like that.
It looks like Jesus,
the one she wants to knock you out with.
She's knocked you out with you.
She's got a hairy knuckles.
Maybe it's just,
no,
I don't think so.
I don't see any hair freckles.
Fuck.
It's tough chick.
But that's the one out there.
What's up?
Have a tote.
That's the one out there that's like,
that's the big money.
If she loses a round in that,
then I'll start watching female MMA.
Well,
this is what I think.
I think the UFC should have a 145 pound women's division.
So see,
like I know about Cyborg and a lot of other people know about Cyborg,
but most people don't have no idea.
Like people that are just UFC fans.
Yeah.
What are they have to 35 and 25 and that's it.
No,
they have 35 in one 15 and 15 and one 15 is the one that is,
uh,
this weekend.
Uh,
Johana you and Jay Chick is a fighting Carlos spars.
Carla Esparza and that's um,
that's for the strawweight title.
Okay.
Straw away.
I love this one.
50 guys fighting.
Yo,
these girls are bad ass to move quicker and a,
the chick Johana,
you and Jay check his Muay Thai world champion elite elite striking skills and
Carl was real tough wrestler.
It's going to be really interesting,
really interesting fight.
But my thing is I think that one 45 they have a one 45 in Invicta,
which is something that the UFC owns.
INVICTA is,
I'm bringing him up.
Maybe they own it or they're part of it.
I don't know if the UFC bought it there somehow or another.
They're working together.
I believe the UFC bought it.
I don't pay attention to the shit I should probably,
it's part of my job,
but that's not nice.
Not a here nor there.
What's,
what's important is they have all women fights.
They have a lot of fighters.
It's like you just bring them all with the UFC.
Let's just bring them over man.
Bring one 45 over and fight in the UFC that if Ronda wants to move up,
let her move up.
We'll then,
not only that,
people will be calling for it,
right.
Cause right now they're not calling for it cause they don't know.
Like I would say.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
Do I understand why they would want to fighter at one 35?
Of course.
Yeah.
That's a smart thing to do.
You're going to find a fucking wrecking machine.
She's big and she knocked bitches out.
You know,
she,
she knocks chicks out in a way that very few fighters knocked being really,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
She puts it on girls.
She puts it on girl.
She's scary.
Um,
everyone should be scared of her.
They all should be scared.
Especially if you're,
if you're a hiker woods in his prime with like when he went eight,
10 tournaments a year,
it's like he was losing 15 tournaments here.
It was at some point challenged.
Well,
yeah.
Obviously that's different though too.
It's like he was beating guys that were like,
Tyson was those 22nd fights in the beginning for sure.
But he was beaten guides that had belts that were like legit.
Like I've heard of this guy before.
I knew Leon Spinks.
I'd heard of him for years.
He brought his brother.
Oh Michael Spinks spanx.
Yeah.
But yeah,
he knocked him out in like 90 seconds was a destruction.
He just ran through him.
Michael Spinks was a legit world champion.
Larry Holmes.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then it was like you're beating those guys.
He beat,
he knocked Larry Holmes out,
man.
Now Larry was past his prime.
I want to say Larry's in his like late thirties now.
Fight.
No,
I think he's too old now.
He's older than me.
I'm 47 I think he's 48 or 49 oh yeah,
he was,
I mean people I didn't have,
I mean,
no actually Jordan.
But the way people talked about when Mike Tyson was fighting,
cause like everyone stopped what they were doing.
You know,
it was like Mike Tyson is coming out.
What do you think?
People just talk about it.
You've seen that documentary,
right?
[inaudible]
you haven't seen the Tyson documentary?
Yeah.
Holy Shit Dude.
It's really amazing.
Yeah,
he tells his life story.
It's incredible.
And that's how they decided to do this one man show,
which I think spike Lee previous is it,
right?
Yeah.
And they do this one man show and Tyson,
it's,
he's killing them all over the world with this show.
Is he showing and traveling and doing?
Yeah.
He did it in a raging bull.
He wasn't in La or in Vegas and he had an la for awhile or did it once it shows
up places and you'd like to do like a run and in a theater and it's good.
Oh yeah.
People love it,
man.
People love it.
His story's incredible.
His grown up on the streets like that.
Yeah.
Praise him.
Pigeons.
They talk about the pigeons.
I forgot about the pigeons.
I don't know if how much they talked about the pigeons cause I,
it's been pigeons.
It's on Hbo Right now.
The Tyson documentary.
See if you can find Mike Tyson talking about,
uh,
what was going through his mind when he's walking to the ring because there's
just one thing where he was talking about what it was like when he was in his
prime,
while he was describing what was going through his mind,
like all his nerves and apprehension and all these different things and how they
would evaporate as you would slowly but surely get closer and closer to the
ring.
Wow.
And then when he go,
when he stepped in through it goes,
once I stepped into that role by I'm a god,
whoa.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Like when he says that,
like I'm a God.
Like that was what's going through his mind.
Like he like he could get to that level that from like start them to finish.
Wow.
Can we just ramp himself up?
And then once he got in there and he looked at his opponent,
he just knew he was just going to smash like Ghostbusters.
Who are you?
Are you are God,
no.
Then Dory,
I just saw it.
There's no way I could remember that.
Intimidation.
I'm pretty much intimidated.
They love to fight the foot.
Even got hit.
Most Guy I knew I needed,
um,
artists got Doug.
He's these guy that knew how to beat these guys psychologically before I even
got in the ring with them.
As soon as I come into the rain that's coming to the ring,
I'm glow.
No stop.
That's not true.
While I'm in the dressing room,
five minutes before I come out,
my gloves are laced up.
I'm breaking my gloves down and Bro,
I'm pushing the lever on the back of my leg in the middle of the glove for my
knuckle.
Compares to the look and feel.
My knuckles peer thing is the tight leather gloves on the Everlast boxing gloves
come out.
I have supreme confidence,
but I'm scared to death.
I'm totally afraid.
I'm afraid of Evec name,
afraid of losing.
I'm afraid of being humiliated,
but I'm totally confident close.
I get to arraign more confidence.
I get the close up,
more confidence.
I get the closer,
more confident I get.
All during my training,
I've been afraid of this man.
I thought this man might be capable of beating me.
I've dreamed of him beating me but that low,
but I always stayed the afraid of him,
but it was closer.
I get to her and I'm more confident once I'm in the ring,
I'm a God.
No one could be,
oh my God,
I'm walking around or him.
I never,
I never take my eyes off my opponent.
I keep my eyes on,
even if he's already in pumping,
he can't wait to get his hands on me as well and keep my eyes on my,
keep my eyes on him.
I keep my eyes on him.
Then once I see a chink in his armor,
boom,
and one of his eyes may move and then I know I have them.
Then when it comes to the senator,
the ring,
he still looks at me with his Pearson looking as if he's not afraid,
but he already made that mistake when,
when he looked down for that one 10th of a second.
I know I hadn't had a fight hard for the first two or three rounds.
I know I already broken spirit.
Did she keep screaming the confidence?
I'm moving my head.
He throwing punches.
Wow.
He's on the ground,
dodge generate.
I'm adding them to the body.
I'm punching the real heart and I'm punching and punching him.
I know he's not able to take my punches.
One,
two,
three punch.
I'm throwing him up.
Punches in bunches goes down.
He's out.
I'm Victoria.
Jesus Christ,
Mike Tyson,
greatest fighter ever.
Live cheese.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
That was cool when he was at it.
I liked that train in fear of this guy beating.
You'll see your train harder.
Yeah.
That's what comics need.
You need confidence when you're on stage,
but lack of confidence every other moment.
Complete like you suck.
Get better,
you suck,
get better.
You definitely can't have a distorted perception.
If you start being a conference you won't get better.
Well it's the one thing that we all despise is a comic who's not
doing well.
Right?
Yeah.
Everybody despises you.
That was great.
Like really?
You're saying that out loud?
That was great.
We just saw you bomb.
You got to admit you bombed.
Otherwise we can talk cause you and I bomb.
I'm going to tell you,
I just hate fucking fat dick up there like fuck like memory.
You call me,
you tell me you had a bad set in London where we talked about it.
Like that shit happens man.
Such a bad,
sad,
devastating.
That's fucking dope books.
So if someone pretends that it's not like we can't talk now,
now we can't talk because now you're not being real.
Do you always own up and be cool?
And they're like,
not every time you win you win everything.
You're the best ever.
It was always the bitch though.
He's a gold medal baby.
Both metal number one in class number one with Jim,
number one football.
If I pick up sports,
I pick a number one is amazing.
Jesus,
that was so cool.
Just a great moment in time.
What he's thinking of as it comes to the,
and that reminds me of what you were thinking of when you're walking through
that hotel fire in San Francisco when she could see right now night
on comedy central.
If you want to see these older stories,
they're on a,
they're on a on demand,
but they're also on youtube.
If you go to it,
this is not happening.
Playlist.
You can see all of them pull the last this year and the last season.
The one before that.
Rogan has got another story too.
Last year.
That's a better one.
Quite honestly.
You think so?
All Right,
nice.
I'll look at that one to shepherd.
The shepherd wants to.
True story too.
I liked how you worked on this one.
It made it better though.
I'd made it better,
but it's just,
it's not as good.
The hotel fire one is just,
the stripper story is just so good.
I remember that bitch still to this day.
Think about her.
She was so crazy.
To this day,
I almost wish I could find a way.
It's like barely stay in touch with her.
Just to clear a doc.
That story too,
like,
I don't know.
I don't do stories,
man.
I don't have any stories.
I'm like,
you have one.
That's amazing.
What about power and I've seen your talent.
Oh yeah.
What's so good about it?
I forgot about that story.
Almost a million views now.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So nice to see you go from,
you know those early days where you trying to become a paid regular,
struggling to see you now while you're balling out of control feels where he
talked you into buying a luxury automobile.
It's not going to happen.
She's fucking frugal bastard.
It's not fruit.
I'm leaving La.
I'm not going to have a car for the next 10 months.
Even like baller
stored outside my apartment that's used that shit and put it like a cardboard
cutout of you with your cock hanging out and leave it there to guard it.
That's how I'll put a for sale.
Sign it.
Which is a big Dick.
That's the price for sale.
Yeah.
I don't even money anymore.
I was poor for too long.
So now my content with very little.
That's nice.
But you're going to get used to like,
what do I do with this money?
I don't have to start buying some shit.
Otherwise it's stupid to have money and then you're gonna.
You know,
I need a car and we're going to go get a car.
Come on,
get a car.
Oh,
I'm just going to get something like a Prius or something that's good on gas and
we'll talk you into a BMW or something.
Yeah.
Exact corrupted.
Like Dunkin Dunkins Karakia and he's got a nice black Mercedes Benz.
Dunkin's corrupted
these bans.
Yeah.
I always told ducking lives large.
Got a tangerine tree in his backyard.
Tangerine little delicious homegrown fruit.
Yeah.
Wonder what,
how,
what,
how pollution affects like plants that you eat like a garden and you're in
silver lake.
You're dealing with some fucking,
some destructive water to cause someone was like,
you gotta wash the outside.
But I'm like,
but it's,
the inside is drinking polluted water and putting that into the fruit.
Yeah,
right.
Depends.
I mean,
most people,
I think in California,
if you have a fruit tree,
you probably have to have some sort of a society irrigation system to flush
water it to water it to,
you're probably watering it from,
if that picks up all the,
all the pollution,
not pollution,
all the,
uh,
the fucking insecticides Po.
Well that's not,
wouldn't be in the water that
like you,
it comes out of your faucet.
Definitely doesn't happen.
Sexercise you think there's insecticides on his plants?
Like the fruit prints?
Yeah.
With spray.
So that face not putting any sprays on his po?
No,
not Dunkin.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm saying someone who grows fruit or vegetables or anything in their house in
Silver Lake.
Yeah.
If you're living in a place that is just gross,
La is polluted.
Polluted.
There's no worry rounded it.
It's definitely not being in the mountains.
So you're right.
So is that in the tangerines to yeah.
How does,
what happens there if the tangerines are breathing the air and they feeds it,
the tree feeds,
yeah.
Think tree scrub more pollution.
Yeah.
We know that.
Right?
Because they eat carbon dioxide,
turns it into something [inaudible] convert them to less harmful compounds.
Well that's harmful.
Yeah.
Not even not harmful.
Less harmful.
It convert.
What is it saying?
Oh,
it absorbs pollutants and turn those into less harmful.
Right.
So it absorbs that and also creates oxygen.
Right?
I mean,
they fuck trees.
You need trees.
Yeah.
But my point is what happens to the fruit?
Like does the lotion in it feels like it would.
Yeah.
It's good to have trees.
If you live in a shit hole.
It's,
everybody's got a science with Joe at Ori.
We don't know shit.
Uh,
I think we're,
yeah,
it seems like it would be a better to have something growing where there's not
cars driving by every day you're going gonna eat it,
you know?
Yeah.
Probably not.
It's probably fucking terrible for you.
It's probably not like less good for you.
That was such a sweet me and Simona at one before he went to the UFC was so
good.
If you could compare that to a tangerine Gresh off the tree though.
It was like extra sweet.
Um,
you know,
it was like still getting nutrients while I was still being shaken while we were
fucking peeling it.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Damn.
It's nice to have.
I used to have a fucking plum tree and it died,
man.
Really?
Yeah,
just got old.
I had it for a long time and it bared a lot of fruit.
It bread like the most fruit like the last couple of years before it petered
out.
Like it's almost like this last few years,
so good.
But it was just that last 4th of July,
you know,
grand finale,
blah blah blah blah,
boom,
boom.
Then yeah,
the fireworks over another that
and then done one year just stopped growing fruit and I was like,
man,
is there something wrong with the,
like the irrigation we checked and it just got old.
Really?
Yeah.
Apparently some fruit trees just get old and they don't make fruit anymore.
Like people just like people,
I don't know what the year things.
I wonder how long had the fucking thing had been there.
I had assumed that whoever had made the house and put it there,
but I think that some people get them like planted as full trees.
Like my neighbor and he grew a fucking orchard.
Orchard.
Orchard looks like it'd be court ordered worker.
He uh,
built one in his front yard.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Oh,
it looks really cool.
He's got like 20 trees over there.
Why don't you trees?
Yeah,
it's got like 20 of them and he installed them all like as full grown trees.
So blocks of view influence,
I mean,
not really.
It's on the side of his house.
Oh,
I thought it's cool though.
It's a pretty big lot and he grows for,
I played Farmville.
I know what time it is.
You do play Farmville?
I did.
Not Anymore.
That is,
that's one of the things that is not up to date on the flip phone is Farmville
Games a week.
Well,
in,
let's talk about this and trying this thing where you've abandoned society and
everything's good,
not advantaged society.
I've gotten off the train.
I'm not even the iPhone slash android and wonderland of apps and videos and
images to two and a half months now go back to a fucking skanky little flip
phone.
Yeah.
Ridiculous little thing that sucks at tests.
Texting.
How much better is you texting gun?
Uh,
it's gotten better.
Absolutely.
I want to get one where it's like the,
the,
the uh,
you know,
the sidekick,
we flip it open,
but too many of those have,
I don't know,
she's gonna ask.
Yeah.
APPS that come standard with it.
What happens when people send you links?
I see the link and I have to email it to myself,
to my kids
sitting.
I can look at it.
I mean,
how do you do it?
Does that,
there's no other way.
That's hilarious.
Now his just fuck with you business wise.
How are you,
should fear dot comedy direct.com?
Yeah.
Everyone go there for my special Ari Shapiro Dot Comedy direction.com has
developed a business at all.
Okay.
If there was any time where I thought maybe I won't be able to handle this,
it's while I had a premiere of my past paid regular special in January,
the show,
the entire run of the show,
which was only two weeks left and passive aggressive.
My other special,
that would be the time,
right when I wouldn't be able to handle it and I'm getting by.
So I got to think in a month or two it's going to be a breeze.
Pluses to minuses.
Okay.
Let's do minus as first.
Let's do my,
um,
I have to text the Twitter.
Oh,
good Lord.
Yeah.
And the Texas t nine so is that the word t nine for that?
So it takes a while.
So you've got to really have in your mind what you want it,
what do you want to tweet?
And when I started tweeting,
uh,
I went to the old,
it was my contacts with Twitter.
It's like,
oh it's four oh four four I think that's what it is.
And I sent a tweet like he used to used to tenant by texts and then they email
me saying,
I think you've been hacked
unless you meant to text a tweet out.
Which by the way,
when you're at the UFC and there's no data,
cause everyone's sharing data.
That's a little trick.
Texts to tweet.
Ooh,
yeah,
you can get shit that you can't check everything,
but you can take something out.
Well yeah,
pictures are harder.
I think you,
it include a subject line or something.
But anyway,
that's difficult.
But I can get it done.
But the pro on the same side is that,
is that I cannot check any twit responses.
That's pro total pro in terms of giving me my time back.
Yeah.
Total pro.
I can't check it.
So why even get lost if I'm doing tweet responses slowly.
I was one of the big ones when I was in an elevator and the doors close.
Well come on.
Here's a negative.
What does that,
there's an amber alert in San Pedro,
California.
And you get it on your phone?
I guess so.
Cause all old ladies have those.
They love that.
I didn't know about that.
What the fuck is this old?
Put It on a meeting.
Old people love those sorts of rounds.
2000 well I'll just fucking pass it along.
A Great Nissan Altima.
2006 California plates lic.
Oh,
I don't know what lic is.
Dash five you see F zero one zero if you see him,
stop him.
Don't wait for the cops.
Yeah,
treat him like you would ted Bundy call it in,
but then no,
don't see us.
Listen,
we were joking.
College or child,
that mother Fucker,
you got a cell phone.
This is why.
Listen to his story first.
He might have a point.
No,
let's no story.
Sometimes when they go amber alert and they go,
his father abducted him.
I'm like,
hmm,
this citizen as cut and dry.
Then it was a terrible story about a woman who with this getting arrested,
she's taken her kid away,
her four year old,
I current her,
her husband Aaron,
some sort of a custody battle and she took the four year old away because he's
getting circumcised.
They wanted to get him circumcised.
Oh she said no phone.
She was like no fucking way.
And so they arrested her and it's just,
you know,
crazy story.
And I see people that are like pro and con and you know,
people do get dry is a,
an abduction.
No like you're still with a parent.
It's just not the weekend.
But there's still like there were threatening her with jail.
Like you know,
she was on the run.
She was like a fugitive.
I mean you can't do that.
But I would say let the cops handle that.
Cut Kids fucking Dick.
Either Jesus Christ.
What is that nonsense?
I don't want to hear any of this or prevents aids.
Shut the fuck up.
That is not preventing any age.
No matter what propaganda they throw your weight girl shaving their vaginas,
prevents a rent.
Say it's cause it's less shaping our,
he's Turkish shaved those buses.
That's not the way to prevent aids.
You fucking geniuses.
Dick wearing condom.
Come on,
be realistic.
I'm talking to people.
Oh yeah.
That,
uh,
think they should cut their kids dick to make them not get aids.
That's not why people are doing it.
It's probably going to get an age anyway and most kind of me age from their
deck.
I'm just won't,
you know,
they get it from somebody else who's doing
the joke.
Here's another negative.
Huge,
Instagram is unusable.
I can do it.
I can do pictures only from my laptop.
I figured out a hack to get to do it.
I don't know that hack.
Tell me after there was,
I think it's going well or something like that.
Oh,
you have to get,
it's a service sucked down into the,
you can just Google it,
but yeah.
Sorry.
Um,
so there's that and you can't really check all your sponsors that much,
but that's good.
Right.
Yeah,
you could definitely get caught up in too much interaction.
You told me something when I told when I was doing this and you said something
that like I've quoted the people when you're like,
well I couldn't live without Instagram and my thought was you did seven months
ago,
you lived without Instagram ads at the time.
You told me that.
So it's like the ideas of what we can and can't live without is like distorted.
I told you that I couldn't live with that answer.
You were half joking,
but like the idea of that,
I was definitely joke.
I mean of course you can live without it.
One thing that I would like,
wow.
You know you love Instagram.
You know what I love about it?
Well,
it could write as much as you want.
You can write several paragraphs,
so can include photograph.
Now you can include a link,
but if you have a photograph that I was like kind of a silly story to it and
it's kind of funny.
Or if you have something that means something to you,
he could actually fill out as long as you want.
You can read it or not read it.
Sort of like,
yeah,
writing a podcast.
Absolutely.
I got on.
I don't believe in,
I'm not 140 I'm not editing shit.
I do a three hour podcasts.
Listen to it.
You don't,
whatever.
I love on skeptic tank.
When I'd finished interviewing somebody,
he's like,
oh,
so you're going to chop that down.
What parts are you going to sound right now man,
unless I have to,
unless you set some incriminating guys.
Love to do that though.
They love to edit them and chop them down and get the right amount and make,
Dan was one of the things that Joey had a problem with with uh,
the young lady that he was doing his last time.
There was some editing going on.
It's like,
why just leave it all Joey fucking Diaz.
Yeah,
yeah.
Figure out what to do.
I get the fuck out of here.
That was the hardest part of this not happening.
What's getting the stories down to time but not lose?
Allow the comments like,
yeah,
riff and we'll take it up.
Doesn't work.
But then at the same time it's like get to like have it.
Yeah,
so like Joey Diaz a story next week here this week he's,
he's gonna be the last one and that'll be the two act breaks because I was like,
guys,
you're not talking about it was,
it was,
you can lose up 30 seconds here,
a mistake,
a story,
but yet you can't so it's over.
There's a commercial in the middle of it.
How long is it total that way?
What?
How long has it totally,
I think it's like 13 minutes long,
but there are like these need to be,
I think you're used to having standup on TV.
It's like seven.
I'm like,
well this ain't that.
Their stories,
the saint that they go as long as they go Joey stories or epic for your story.
We had to get right to ask them.
I was like,
listen,
I know the act breaks are seven and a half Max.
His story is eight and a half.
Can you just like take the time off another outbreak?
And they were like,
let us check.
And they're like,
yeah,
look great.
Thank you.
Have a certain amount of minutes.
That's what it is.
You know?
That's,
that's something that's really interesting too because I watched you developed
that from doing it to annex room.
The little small rooms there on the side stage.
Yeah.
Was just like you were just trying to stretch.
Just fuck around and see,
see what happens.
See what exactly,
My storytelling has gotten a lot better from doing it for five years.
Oh I would imagine.
Well guys like Joey Diaz or guys like Charlie Murphy.
How do you think they got so good at telling stories?
He told a lot of God damn stories.
You've been telling stories forever.
Like Charlie Murphy can captivate you with those God damn stories cause he's
been around dues that are good at it.
He picked up how to do it by doing his own stories over and over again.
You realize the rush you get when someone is telling,
like when Joey's telling a great story and we are howling laughing.
Even if it's just the three of us at five guys burger,
we're having a great time.
Yeah.
I mean it might as well be a packed room filled with a thousand that's a theory
behind it.
But it's like you've entertained people like this and you're a comedian so your
natural like when people say like what do you do?
You just talk.
It's like yeah but it's a comedian just talking.
That's what a podcast is.
So it's always way funnier a comic telling a story,
especially if they're good at it.
Like Joey ideas.
Yeah.
Joey has some of the most epic stories of all time.
He has a couple on there.
If you haven't seen them,
this is not happening.
Playlist,
go to youtube.
Just look at all of how many does he have on your thing?
He's got to cause I was like yeah,
we're going to come back the second season and they were like do you want to
have people back that have already done the digital one for TV?
And I was like yeah,
dos and big journey of course and Rogan.
Like what do you mean?
Yes,
yes,
we're just going to do that.
Like people have more than one story.
I said funny though that like when you,
when you dealing with like a giant company now we're dealing with a bunch of
people.
You used to just doing,
doing what I want,
what you want and doing what you think is funny when you do a podcast,
when you do anything.
Yeah.
But like when you actually have to like cooperate with other people and you have
to have these conversations about the direction of the show,
that's all new.
That's very new.
Being a producer is newest.
Fuck yeah.
And I don't know how to do it and I don't know those rules and like you can't
tell this person then I'm like,
why?
They have to like help me through it.
But the thing is if as long as we,
what I found,
as long as you explain to someone with logic what you want to do,
then they'll go,
okay,
sure we'll do it that way.
Like when I was editing my special paid regular enough,
not the one that's coming out on Friday,
passive aggressive,
such a dvs,
uh,
Friday night,
midnight,
1159,
59.
And they were like,
oh,
we don't like this angle,
can you change it?
And I was like,
actually we use the other shot of that and there's somebody picking their nose
right by the stage,
something like that.
And so that's why we can't use that shot.
They go,
oh,
okay,
great.
So then use the one you want to use them.
If you just explained to them,
right,
like there's no fight,
then they're totally cool people.
Well this group of people that are running comedy central now are awesome artist
friendly.
That shit about letting you get eight and a half minutes.
It's like a sign of like,
cool,
you understand?
Let's update.
Some stuff will come into the future a little.
And they're all cool about it.
They were great through your show.
They were great through when I was filling my special,
they were great when you were filling your special.
They're just nice people and they,
they enjoy what's going on.
They ain't [inaudible] to their comedy fans.
So they kind of,
they're what they really want is something awesome and come out,
plug our,
we give them a plug,
Jonas.
And,
and they're great,
great people and keep them up.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Yeah.
They're cool people to hang out with them.
This is a really good time for comedy,
man.
It's really two good time at the store.
That's a really good time on comedy central.
It's a really good time.
There's a lot of funny fucking comics.
We just put up a show tomorrow night.
What's today?
Monday,
Wednesday night.
It's already sold out.
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
Bitches.
Yeah.
Diaz.
Um,
Brian Cowen,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Ian Edwards in Maine.
People are calling from meetup debate.
Brendan Schaub on American sniper.
That's a good show though.
Fuck you and him debating Americans typer.
You debate anybody.
I need to get permission to 'em from you to release that video.
You're disparaging arm heroes.
I didn't know.
I have no secrets.
There's no permissions for me.
I seem to remember that being a very controversial statement.
Oh really?
In their behalf and I'm not sure you want that public.
Well,
I said it was a Shitty fucking movie.
Everybody wants me to debate.
It's like you're not going to debate the acting.
I'm not going to bake Chris Kyle in any way.
I'm doing it.
The acting and the storytelling in that movie.
Hey Bro,
bro,
you gotta fucking guy's a hero,
bro.
Yeah,
but so what?
That fucking scene where he met his wife was garbage,
bro,
bro.
Bro.
Respect.
Okay.
It's about the Christopher Columbus respected shoot that scene more than once.
Fucking Eastwood.
You old man.
What you and fucking,
what's his name?
[inaudible] go suck each other off.
And your old man camp.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh.
A wrinkled caucus in each other's mouth and go fucking support shitty comedy
again.
You guys are garbage Darya.
They've lost it.
Unforgiven was amazing.
Let's not take that away from him.
How old was he when he made unforgiven?
1520 years ago.
It was great and it was a,
it was a culmination of all the stuff he had done to the point.
To that point.
He made a real western.
You're upset with our,
with Howard stern because he said that shit about podcasting.
That's the new thing.
I'm upset with Howard stern over.
It just shows what a fucking,
how much he's lost touch.
Like that's not the way you become a radio DJ started.
No one wants to become a radio DJ who's doing podcast.
That's not our end goal.
He might be doing that though.
He's a very clever guy.
He might be doing that just to get people to talk shit and for losers.
So that means anyone who listens to a podcast and listen to Howard Stern,
just so you know how it's turned,
called you a loser for listening to podcasts as well.
You gotta know how to take it to an act break.
What?
No,
you don't.
You can just not go to an act break the fuck are you talking about?
Take it back to the thirties I think he was trying to fuck with people.
I really do.
No,
I think he doesn't like the and where are you going to make your pennies?
And he goes,
Corolla shouldn't be in podcasts.
They should be doing radio.
Like you just don't even know what it is.
You're commenting on shit.
You don't even know what it is.
I don't know man.
I hear that from a guy like that.
He's too clever.
He was too Glover.
I think he's probably,
I don't know.
I think he's probably fucking with people,
Dude.
At the same time dancing with the stars.
What does that a prank?
I think it's chance for the stars.
America's got talent,
whatever garbage show he likes it.
He likes giving people.
When he talks about it,
it genuinely seems like he's enjoying it.
Giving people the opportunity,
like some of those people that come out of that show are actually really
talented,
cool jugglers and stuff.
I don't know.
I've never obliged.
What are you doing that show for Tom Cotter?
Tom Cotter standup comic.
He's the guy that I came up with in Boston like way back in the day.
Hold on a second and you should know,
but I don't want Tom caught her at all,
but there's no way you're going to defend that show by saying Tam,
fucking Katar,
he's been fucking shitty since 84 there's no way you're going to say that as an
example of something good coming out of that show.
Fucking cool dancers.
Yeah,
I'll give you that.
Cool.
You do?
I like Bob Carter.
I can't say any bad.
No,
you can't because you know him and like him,
but I can cause I've never him.
He's a beautiful human being.
I was a little kid watching live for the laugh factory on Saturday night.
I was like,
who's this fucking cheese ball host?
How dare you?
That's really amazing,
Jonathan,
dare you.
How dare you are.
You should fear.
You gave him a TV show.
The mother fucker goes on a rampage.
Paul's out attacking Howard stern attack.
Attack Hotter.
When's the last time he broke up real musician anymore?
I don't think he ever did that.
Did he really?
Yeah.
Bands like sole coughing.
I remember discovering them through Howard stern is a good band.
Your rights stern.
Oh listen to rock music,
but now he's fucking 104 and hundred and four year olds don't have their finger
on the pulse.
I don't think he's at all.
That's why.
That's why the guy from side live,
he just like,
well,
hire a young black people just to hire somebody that is young.
I think I'm honestly,
this is my take on it.
I want to be completely objective.
I think what he's doing is what he enjoys.
Yeah.
This is who he is now.
It's just who he is now.
We can't want a guy to be who we thought he was or who he used to be.
There's nothing Comedians,
uh,
athletes,
musicians.
No one keeps up at the high level.
They perform at all the time they fade.
But this is where I think you're wrong because starring has really good
interviews.
They're really good.
Still new ones.
Very good.
Okay,
well then kid rock,
he's very good.
He's,
I think he's one of the very best ever at,
yeah.
At like getting the interview.
All right,
well then it's a good interviewer still.
He's still very good man.
He might have some ideas that I don't agree with.
Like the podcasters are losers,
but he's still like that guy is like,
if you go back and look at all the radio influences like that guys,
the number one radio guy,
oh,
hold on Sam.
Kinison Houston,
like Sam Kinison.
It was like,
this guy's legit funny and now he likes fucking one liner comics.
Well,
safe one liner comics.
I don't know.
I bet he's still,
they're funny comics too.
I don't,
I don't buy it man.
I mean,
I don't talk to the dude on a regular basis.
I haven't seen him in a long time.
You can get the black keys.
I was like,
man,
I don't get it.
Why?
Why do we want to have them on really irrelevant man.
They had to force them into his playing his birthday party because he was like,
I just wouldn't,
he wouldn't play them.
I you sure about that.
That's who played his birthday party,
right?
Yeah,
but he showed it.
He didn't want them and I just wouldn't have them.
No,
I'm not sure about anything,
but that's what I heard.
Oh,
that I heard shit.
That's what I hear from people who listened to him.
I don't know man.
If it wasn't for him,
it wasn't for all the shit that he went through with the FCC and all the shirts
and then he tries to say that ONA went too far having a homeless guy on and it's
like,
dude,
fuck you.
You are relevant piece of shit.
Well,
you know what I'm saying on the side of freedom only when it's your freedom of
speech.
No one else's,
his enemy and his,
that was his idea was that his enemies,
he would go after with all of his weapons,
weapons,
weapon as a mortar,
mortgaging his fucking art and what he believes in that people should be allowed
to say whatever they want.
That is what it's all about,
right?
I mean it's got to kind of be
that and it's got to kind of stand up for itself.
You've got to say like fuck those guys,
but of course Israel and say what they want,
but please everyone,
do not listen to them because they suck.
That's what you should say.
Hmm.
Or just shouldn't say that one too far.
You can't say certain things like,
come on man,
do you want to far a hundred times.
And it was great.
And other line with moved.
Do you think that's because like in those days when they had time slots that the
time slot was the king and maybe that's why we're not like that at all.
You think about it all the funny drive time was huge to get that all of our
friends,
what all of our friends have podcasts and we're always on all of our friends
podcasts.
I've been on yours,
you've got ideas.
I've been ideas is we're all like on each other's podcasts Dunkin's last week.
Yeah.
And this is never like have a,
it's not a competitive thing at all.
Like it doesn't even come into play.
It's like,
Hey,
we all have successful podcasts,
this is fun and we just keep doing podcasts.
And no one's worried that somehow or another if they download the skeptic tank
that they're not gonna Download Duncan trussell's family hours catch up with all
the old ones and they move on to the next podcast.
Exactly.
And there's enough people,
there's a lot of people.
And the key isn't controlling the people that are there.
The key is promoting as much good shit as possible so that more people show up
and then everybody's happy.
Right?
Like this idea that you have to be,
but when there was one morning show,
you know one guy got the morning shift and you have rankings,
we're the number one in our market that got all the money.
Of course the smart guys going to want to give her the money,
so we're doing better and it's like rankings.
Those iTunes rankings that came out and people start doing podcasts.
Everyone's interested at first and then it became like whatever,
who cares?
I have this many downloads.
I want to get more.
Yeah,
I want to get more people to listen.
And it's like that's a different world like that.
That's a different world of competition,
different worlds,
and you're not,
you can't,
can't accept this new world where people don't care is it is definitely a new
world.
There's all,
there's a lot of people listening to podcasts and especially when you have
something happen to us too.
We're going to become a relevant,
oh,
I don't know about that.
I think you'll be relevant with people that are interested in what you have to
say.
Maybe that's what it is that you change.
You change just for comedians where it's like when you're 60 and irrelevant,
the 60 year olds,
six year olds don't go out to the comedy clubs.
Okay,
but here's the,
you're still relevant to Europe.
No audience.
Okay.
Here's the argument against that is dom I rera diamond Herrera is not just
relevant.
He's just funny as ever.
Yeah,
that's true.
Murders it.
Good point.
I saw him the other night.
We did kill Tony together like one the other night for a few months ago and he
was sharp as I've ever seen him really crushing off the top of his head.
Hilarious.
Vicious,
hilarious.
Self deprecating.
We just monstrous.
Wow.
Just smashed it.
Smashed it.
We were howling laughing.
He's so good at that.
Off the cuff stuff.
Especially he's talking to like young Comedians,
you know?
It was,
it was,
it was excellent.
So there's,
there's some guys that just stay funny.
I,
Dom Irrera just stayed funny.
He never stopped being funny.
He just stayed funny.
Carlin's last few years was a downturn.
I think his health was a big issue.
I think when you,
you're struggling with your health,
so leave society more.
How you going to talk about being of the people when you just like,
you're not of the people they've flown coach and fucking 15 years,
20 years coach,
right.
So whatever it is,
but it's like you've never taken the subway.
If you do a joke about the subway,
would you have no idea what it's like now.
If it's true,
you know,
I wonder how much,
I mean he used to hang out with the comedy store.
I really regret not talking to him.
Not too tempting to talk to him.
I said hello.
It was very friendly.
He said hi people.
Whenever I heard people call him,
Mr Carly's like short,
please just call me George.
Yeah.
It was kind of cool.
He was,
he was a really like a comic.
He took me out 20 bucks did man,
I'm sure he did.
He seemed very friendly when I said hello to him.
I just real quick,
somebody must deal with all the time people coming out to them river revering
him.
Yeah.
I just had to get away from him before I said something stupid,
but I was just,
it was psyched.
I was psyched that he was there.
I was like,
wow,
that's George fucking Carlin.
Holy Shit.
You know,
there's like a mount Rushmore of comedy.
He's,
there's the,
uh,
the date rape Guy Guy.
Just start calling him that to take that guy.
Carlin,
it's fucked up man.
But you got to kind of remove him from the Mount Rushmore of this crap.
No,
no.
You do not have to do that.
You cannot deny someone the hall of fame because of off the field actions.
That's got nothing to do with it.
I just lost fucking the dead girl's made him funnier.
They weren't dead.
They were out cold,
close to the deck,
out cold girls made him funny or then that's a performance enhancing drug.
But otherwise has nothing to do with his act.
But pod is a performance enhancing drug when it comes to that.
So Asterix.
Prior Carlin
don't ask Cosby cause he probably,
he probably did smoke pot too.
What?
It came and now he goes,
I'd like to admit pot.
Oh Wow.
People be like,
I have a confession.
I smoked pot when I do feel bad about some of the things I did.
I want to talk about those things.
I'm willing to admit bad things and that's all I'm willing to admit.
So it must be all there is much.
That was the worst borderline black person slash bill Cosby impression that we
both did.
Horrible,
horrible impression.
I can't do it as much as I can do.
I'm not,
I can't do coffee.
I remember Thomas Ward,
he'd do a fucking cop.
He said God's going to pour.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
You did fuck it.
But he played,
caused me to point.
I saw it on the shelves at the Old Hustler.
Well,
he used to do it at the store.
He used to do a Crosby at the store.
God crazy.
Hey,
we're doing,
if you want to come,
you can just pop in if you want,
but we're doing comedy store stories and the belly room when a couple of
Tuesdays in a couple of Tuesdays.
Yeah.
Let me know in advance if I can make it and it's just gonna be Illinois.
I'll go ask dom.
I just got the idea when you said it.
Tell him fucking shit that's happened at the store.
Yeah.
This is probably some really funny stories.
I'll just get a bunch of people haven't remind you of other stuff.
I wonder if anybody's gonna.
I would like to hear Carla go tell his ghost or your various coasts story.
I wonder how much of his bullshit,
I'd like to sit down,
dude,
down to a lot of technical dancers,
all of it.
Because no ghosts.
If you told me to go story,
unless it ends with someone pulled off a sheet,
then I have some theories.
I'll share them with you.
Okay.
Um,
Carlo has this great story and I remember he told it one night at the comedy
store.
There's some special night,
I forget what the night was all about,
but it wasn't just a comedy night.
There was like a movie they were playing or something like that.
And uh,
I was in the back of the room and Carlo had the audience captivated and he was
telling the story about how when he was broke and when he was down on his luck
and is his comedy career was going nowhere.
You know,
maybe he's personal life.
He had issues,
like everything was all fucked up,
but he showed up at the comedy store cause he had the keys cause he worked there
and he said,
I'm just going to sleep on the stage,
man.
This is where I'm going to fucking make my dreams happen.
I'm going to sleep right here on this stage.
And so,
uh,
he said he went to sleep and he's lying on the stage.
Um,
and I'm so sorry if he gets offended in me telling a story,
he tells it way better.
You want to hear it from him.
Um,
and he said that he was lying there on the stage and that he heard the door
open.
Yeah.
And he waited and he didn't hear anything and it's totally dark.
Shuts all the lights out so I can go to sleep.
And he says,
uh,
Hey,
it's me,
Carl,
I'm in here.
I let myself in.
I got a,
I got kicked out of my apartment,
right.
It doesn't hear anything.
It's total darkness out there.
And he hears like a little thump or click like you can tell that someone's in
the room.
He's like,
hello eight sites,
uh,
Carla bows here,
you know,
so,
and then he says he hears like chairs moving like,
like someone's coming towards him and he can't see cause the rooms totally dark.
So he opens his eyes and he lifts his head up and something grabs his ankle and
pulls him off the stage and knocked to the ground and then here is running.
And then he hears a door slam and that's it.
And he said he never saw anybody and he tells it to you and it makes the fucking
hairs on your forum.
I love those stories,
but this is why I love it.
He was doing drugs with Sam Kinison.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
you talked to mark Marin,
revere him,
Mark Marin,
Sam Kinison story.
He was hearing voices in his head for a year.
Right.
That's how hard cards door.
Like I saw things fall.
I'm like,
well,
I've seen comics hide back there waiting to scare other comics,
so what's more likely,
especially if they knew that you were going back there and your checks or yeah,
exactly.
Or comic fucking with somebody once more like it's 100% of comic fucker.
That's exactly what it is.
But it's a great story because that's in his world that that's reality.
It was a great,
I'm telling you,
man,
when he told it to me in my fucking yeah.
In his mind that that is what happened.
He's decided to look no further.
This Sam died too.
It was like tough.
Yeah.
That's awful.
That's awful shit man.
That's all bull shit you got.
Here's the,
have you seen the LSC story yet?
Who Always Duke?
No,
just Houston comic.
Talking about finding other comics and stuff.
Yeah.
Funny.
It's on your show and your show.
Yeah.
There's some
see somebody doing like a good story hit Larson.
J T has of course James.
Amazing.
Bert big j.
Stories are really good.
He's a natural storyteller.
I really enjoy.
I really enjoy watching that guy do your show.
I enjoy talking to them.
It's a natural like storyteller type dude.
Great at referring to,
but he'd stay.
Then it goes into a story and it's like everyone's like the waitresses.
Everyone's like looking and listening and it's like they're just fucking great.
That when he told about the dog was the one I wanted to do like two years ago on
this show.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but he was like,
no,
I think I use it for a special,
but then no one gave him a special and he's like,
okay,
I'll put it on something.
I was like,
thank you.
Yes.
Awesome.
That's a good idea of man.
Yeah.
Hey,
but he,
he's one of those guys,
like there's certain guys that are really funny and they're their material.
Like the subject matter becomes like just a scaffolding for funny,
for funny Shaklee.
And that's like with him,
like that guy,
she just keep putting things out as much as possible.
Just build up this metal crowd work album.
It's got podcasts and stuff,
but it's like,
yeah,
he's more clips.
Yeah,
there's a good crop of those guys out there now.
It was like a real good crop of like really funny guys who'd been Metzker,
which I don't know if just because I made friends with them from the nasty shows
in Montreal.
I did it one year,
then two years later I did it again.
And those guys were like the,
at my level guys.
Why you hung out the most?
You know Justin look to one year,
but like,
um,
I just think they're amazing but I don't know if it's cause I'm friends with
them or not,
but they're both like on a such a high level and Metzker well it's like when I
was saying about you when you first started,
it's just a matter of just putting in the time to get people to see you.
I see you guys funny.
They put in the time,
they do a lot of sets to keep working on their act.
Everything you do,
whether it's playing the harmonica or fucking have you put enough time and
enough time and you just get better at it,
you get better.
She the video,
which one?
He,
he uh,
he broke down crying.
He said that some deal fall through and so he's on a podcast and cried about it.
So then on his podcast that he's been doing for the Legion of skanks,
they had a bunch of comics like record videos for them making fun of him crying.
Dude,
can you find the one?
I made them play that for a job.
So I just sat there for like 45 minutes trying to come with like something good
to like,
like therefore him like a 62nd video and then,
Oh,
here's my point.
Lewis put it up online.
That's why I don't care to put it best snipers shit.
Okay,
I got,
I got asked the girl if it's okay.
You're holding guys.
You would shower.
Champix you've got your fucking mind.
Alright,
listen,
notable President Barack Obama.
I can't talk right now.
I've got to make a video for big j overson person.
Dude can't use words like that.
It's a homophobic word.
Whatever we all learn to talk to you later.
Paki Paki
what's that called?
I heard about the deal.
That fucking sucks,
Bro.
Fucking sucks.
This business
never stopped shitting on your fucking grave.
I get it.
I got a deal right now with my own billboard being up on sunset boulevard,
giant 30 foot picture,
my face staring down sunset from my,
from my old apartment building.
I'm not going to
comment.
Go cry to your mother beds.
His,
it was a business and his big J.
Oh no,
no.
This is wrong.
That's wrong,
and I think it's illegal.
We probably shouldn't have showed that you're going to get in trouble.
He made a dog touch your ass with his face.
I think it's sexual to say it wasn't sexual to you.
It seemed like it was some sort of BCL.
We should end the podcast.
We're going to have to edit that out.
We'll be back.
We'll be right back
in jail for having a dog liquor.
But I wonder if it's like totally legal
to do anything about it.
But you know Paul,
it was very rapey.
He didn't want to go [inaudible].
They didn't want to be there for sure.
It was like,
Oh,
I'm not opening my mouth on this,
but here's what we say.
His personal freedom is not worth as much as how funny that was.
Yeah.
And that's what a comic,
we'll say in a peta person won't exactly.
Peter showing up at your shows before they show up in mind.
Peter feedings at first to get pumped up,
shooting them an email,
thanking them,
lick your ass.
I texted
you so fucking cool it.
They kill a lot of animals themselves.
Oh yeah.
They put,
you know,
cats and dogs down.
I'm sure they don't want to Dunkin alone.
One time when he was probably dating some Vegan,
there was like 10,
12 years ago,
he knew Peter,
I think his brother might've worked for Pete Up.
We went down to the store,
some high price store in Beverly Hills and Prada store and there was,
there was,
they were selling like sealskin coat or something,
a baby seal skin.
So somebody dressed up like a c and we beat the fuck out of them with rubber,
with rubber bands.
Oh,
how rude.
And sprayed blood on them.
It was great.
So much fun right in front of the product store.
And they're like,
well,
we didn't do it.
We just think they give us whatever they give us.
I'm just the manager here.
That's so rude.
It was great.
It was so much fun.
Press came.
So you are committed to never,
never,
um,
compromising and becoming a different person.
Like maybe perhaps someone who could host a talent show on television committee.
Here's your talent show.
But here's the deal.
All eventually get swayed.
He thinks I'll become old and I'll lose my touch and then I'll be,
I see everybody do it.
Eventually they just start coasting and they do shit that it's like it's good
enough.
I don't think so.
Dude did this one for the money.
You don't have to.
No,
you don't have to.
But a lot of people do it be Koski never did it.
Mm.
He was poor in the end.
Well maybe not in the Andy.
Probably all those books,
but I don't know,
man.
I,
I definitely sold out a lot when I did fear factor.
I did a lot of selling out.
But you weren't doing something that I didn't want to do for money.
So that is essentially you're selling your time,
but here's the problem.
Here's the difference there.
You were doing something,
which I assume,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I assume you thought what you were doing was funny and I that it was,
no,
no.
Not fear factor.
Oh,
last time.
What News?
Radio.
Oh,
fear of falling.
No,
nears written his radio.
I'm very proud of Fairfax job.
There's just a lot of money.
There was no way to pass on it.
But what it made sure that I never did.
You weren't caught doing corny jokes for that?
No.
They weren't making you seem corny.
Shit.
No,
they weren't making me do corny shit,
but I wouldn't,
I didn't change my standup.
Right.
My stand up,
I did exactly the same way I would've done it with her had a TV show or not.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean,
when you have a show that's like a lot of kids watch that show and you got,
there was only a lot of,
yeah,
but you could've gotten a wider audience if you just started doing super safe or
shit then because you were on NBC show,
I bet you could attract all those people that come see you in the theater when
you weren't doing theaters.
Um,
what do you like your mortgage to you?
Where I would have changed my act entirely.
I know a lot of this family comics who want to talk about dark shit,
but they're like,
I got this audience where I can't.
It's like,
yeah,
fucking death.
He a man as an artist,
that's the death of you as the death.
Knowing who your audience is,
the worst.
If you get fired,
it's a good story.
It's,
you know,
look,
you only did it in the first place to make money,
but just pretend you never got the job in the first place and he got a nice
little boost in your,
uh,
publicity because you get fired for doing what you love to do.
[inaudible]
it's show and it's fine.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just feel like people change.
Dude,
this is what I,
that's what it is to people change and then they're not quite as like big time.
Well it's under the not,
not even quite as big time.
Like what they think is different than what they thought when they were 20 or 30
or 40 or 50 like,
like the Howard Stern.
He,
he just a different dude.
But I think that's part of lose,
losing relevancy.
Is that relevant?
I made how many old people you that he's not relevant to.
Maybe.
Maybe that's what it means.
Maybe being not being relevant means you're not relevant to a spending.
You know they have the demographic and the 18 to 35 year old boys is like big
cause I do the net spending because they're nuts.
Yeah.
They don't have wives,
but like,
so you're relevant to like a Matlock top crowd when it's like they don't see who
watched Matlock.
Yeah.
And murder.
She wrote,
you're using like references.
They were at a date when I was,
I was like a 15 that's what that was.
I don't have the,
I don't know what the new show shows for old people are and I know what it is.
It's America's got talent.
Oh,
how dare you.
So you're doing stuff for old people and they're not spenders.
Then I could go see movies.
Do you agree that he's like the most important radio guy of all time?
I would probably say that.
Yeah.
Other than the guy who had invented the radio.
This is the most important.
Yeah,
for sure.
He changed the way everybody talks.
I don't want to take away his legacy.
I want to stop talking about him.
How dare you.
That's what it is.
I want to talk about it in the past at,
I mean not right now.
I mean as like he was one of the best,
if he had died 15 years ago you,
there'll be nothing new bad coming in.
Wow.
So you wouldn't have to like disparage him.
So he's just in that same thing with Dan with all these people that have had
their peak and now they're on the downturn and they like don't don't shit on me.
But it's like we're not shitting on,
you were just really revering where you were at your height.
It was amazing.
A baseball player is not quite as good.
It doesn't mean he wasn't the best for four years in a row,
you know,
seven years ago and now you're just contributing players,
not like fuck you contributing player.
It's like
you are amazing for awhile.
That's awesome.
That's going to happen no matter what though.
Especially with athletes.
Young athletes is the real big one.
I mean,
it's just like it's going to happen and they used the greatest of all time ever
reveres you and then you get caught taking steroids at two different occasions
during a training camp.
I can tell you all about that.
You're going to,
I'll tell you a story when we get off air.
Okay.
I tell you on air that's you're going to go,
oh,
all right.
Um,
Could be more to the story.
I can't,
I'm not under a,
okay,
but let me ask you a question and you don't have to answer this at all,
but why,
who I love Jon Jones,
but why does he not get suspended for coke and Nick Diaz get suspended every
time for weed in a legal state.
I can try to eliminate for that.
Um,
there is out of contest testing and then there's in contest test.
So if you're calling your lawyer,
yes.
If you,
if he was under the influence of cocaine,
by the way,
I think.
Okay.
Should be totally not something that UFC should worry about it either.
Yeah,
I think that's like a law thing that they should not test for.
Well maybe bugs and help your performance.
Somebody cocaine and they're in a fight and they're getting their ass kicked or
there it's a really brutal fight and they're worn out.
You gave them cocaine like they,
they believe happened with Aaron prior when he fought Alexis Aguayo the getting
coke in the middle of a fight.
This is what the thought.
That's different then.
But go ahead.
Alexis Arguayo and Aaron Pryor had this fucking amazing fight.
Aaron Pryor went on to become,
I mean he was a world champion at the time,
but he went on to become a,
I'm a junkie.
He,
uh,
was a coke head.
He had a real,
real big,
big problem.
Coke and just his life fell apart.
But when he was on,
he was an amazing fighter.
This guy,
Panama Lewis is in his corner and he asked for the bottle,
but you know,
he goes,
not that one.
The other one that I mixed,
Oh really?
Give him this bottle.
I think it was a black bottle.
He drinks from this bottle and he comes out and fucking destroys our quail,
puts them away in the next round.
And the question was,
was there any illegal substance in that bottle or was it just total coincidence
that Aaron Pryor came out and destroyed him?
And s when is a bottle that he mixed?
I mean,
who knows?
He could have been coconut water.
We don't know if it didn't destroy them.
No one would have thought twice about the second bottle.
But here's the problem that seemed guy was involved in a fight where these two
guys,
one of them,
I believe his name was Billy resto and another one was,
I forgot his name.
Um,
but he was a young Irish kid and he was a really good fighter and he was an up
and coming prospect and he fought this Guy Louie Resto.
Yeah,
Louie Resto and Billy Collins Jr I think it was.
Yeah.
My memory is like a fucking steel traps.
Um,
and Louie Resto just fuck this kid up.
He was a guy that was supposed to be like a,
a journeyman guy who was fucked up.
He fucked him up and he was hurting him with every punchy through.
And,
uh,
he was telling his corner,
you know,
like,
this guy is hurting me with every punch he throws when they were like,
this guy's not a big puncher,
like this kind of crazy.
After the fight that father goes up to this resto guy and grabs his glove and
there's no padding and his gloves,
uh,
they'd pulled the padding out of the gloves,
the same trainer,
Panama Lewis,
the guy,
and he was banned for history,
for life from boxing.
He wound up working with Mike Tyson later on in his career.
And when he worked with Mike Tyson,
like he couldn't do the corner.
Like I don't,
he wasn't allowed.
No,
Wow.
So I don't know how,
like,
how much work he did with them or I might not have been any,
might've been trying to get relevant again.
But,
uh,
so it kind of lends a least a little bit of suspicion to the Aaron prior
incident and the fact that prior became a cocaine addict.
But it's always been a subject of extreme contrast.
Maybe that yeah,
they shouldn't have it in competition cause I can see that helping you actually.
Yeah.
If you've got a guy who does a lot of coke gotta pay you gotta Pay Jesus Christ,
you're okay.
He panicked.
Panicked.
You would think a man with a billboard would be a little more cool.
Motherfuckers gotta build bar.
Um,
we should probably find that clip for the folks while they listen in here.
Find a clip of a,
um,
Aaron Pryor,
the secret bottle with Panama Louis Cause there's a,
um,
there's like a video of it.
If you're a boxing historian,
you might already know about this because it's probably one of the most
important like,
uh,
controversies in the history.
Another one is when Ali,
when Muhammad Ali was young,
uh,
he fought Henry Cooper,
who is this British gentleman who was an excellent fighter as well.
And Henry Cooper hit Ali with a fucking left hook that was on the button,
sat him on his ass and really had him fucked up.
I mean he was really hurt and in their corner,
Angelo Dundee cut Ali's gloves so that cut his gloves.
So they had to change his gloves.
Like his gloves are cut.
We've got to change the gloves.
He got cut his fucking glove in a corner because Henry Cooper blasted Ali into
fucking Lalala.
Got An extra time.
Yeah.
Pull that.
That's actually more interesting.
Watch Henry Cooper Kaos Muhammad Ali put,
pull this video up cause it is pretty interesting.
Another,
this is going to be with the breath and of this weekend in Sacramento at the end
of the month,
could have heard the [inaudible] dot com for tickets.
Do I applied?
Um,
I,
this is when Ali was Cassius Clay's before he became really Holly.
Yeah.
Cut It to,
to save time to help.
Like oh yeah,
yeah.
He,
well he got hit by this guy,
Henry Cooper was famous for his left hook cracks.
Ali went and Benny when he was Cassius clay on the button drop some.
And then Mohammed Ali,
he sits down in between rounds here go,
we could play it.
You hear it?
Watch this.
Oh,
Jesus knocked him through the ropes to,
it's right at the bell.
So he got up like it's literally at the Buzzer.
Hi Ben.
See what they're not play in now this is [inaudible].
They didn't show the controversy mercy
because it did to that.
Yeah,
I didn't,
they didn't go right to the next round.
Like they're,
they edited out all that Shit.
This is,
this is trying to,
I don't know if somebody did this to try to protect legacy or if they wanted to,
uh,
just sitting,
you know,
there were a Mohammad Ali fans,
they want to highlight the good stuff.
But in between rounds,
after Henry Cooper dropped him his corner,
bottom time they cut the gloves.
Angelo Dundee,
I just took the,
took a razor and cotton so that,
okay,
we can't fight it.
You got to change the gloves.
And I think he might've even had to run to the back that change the gloves.
Let me see if it's a,
but that was like probably the most famous of all the controversies next to the,
nobody beat him at the next round.
Yeah,
well he cut him
and uh,
when he caught them,
um,
the,
they wound up stopping the fight because Ali was just boxing them up with the
punches.
Right.
I don't know.
I think he eventually cut him,
but it was the punch that dropped him,
which was the crazy thing.
So that's why they would,
they would,
they would ban because Nick Diaz was on weed.
Well,
there's fighting,
yeah.
The difference between fighting when you're on weed and by the way they changed
the,
the amount that you could have.
Like it used to be much lower threshold.
Like you'd have trace elements of marijuana and they would say you tested
positive for marijuana,
but they raised the threshold and Nick Diaz was still three times over the
limit.
It's not like he's a guy,
he's even saying,
I don't take it.
He's fully admitting all the time,
like,
can I smoke weed all the time?
Let's see if they play it here.
This is in between rounds.
Let's see.
Gloves,
controversy
still happening.
Yeah.
Oh look at that punch.
I mean he literally sat him down on his ass.
Hi.
So they're putting smelling salts on them.
No Way.
He doesn't know where he is.
He couldn't fight like that.
Oh my God.
Listen
[inaudible]
hi.
But not around five.
So they bought him all that time.
So instead of it being a minute in between rounds,
man,
I don't know how long it was like he was going on at the time.
People to us and something.
I probably took some some out of that.
Yeah.
It looked like they'd probably edit it a little bit.
Something out of that.
I wonder how long it took.
Interesting.
Yeah,
it is interesting man.
I mean that's,
we think of,
especially boxing lore.
Yeah.
You don't want to think that he got knocked down.
He had to get to the top by being the best ever.
He had a,
when all the fights,
he had to be undefeated.
That's what everybody they wanted.
That guy's never been touched.
Yeah,
we don't,
you don't want a guy that has a knockout loss.
To me.
It's so much more interesting when the champions,
when they go back and forth like it seemed like the raging bull days and stuff
where it's like,
yeah,
you have three,
four,
five losses,
so did somebody else,
but you guys are the best two in the world.
You know,
you revenged all your losses.
Avenged I don't know.
Something like that where you can be touched.
Yeah.
Di Angelo Dundee smelling salts under Clay's knows that's not electric,
which was illegal.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
a spare set of gloves,
so they did definitely change his gloves.
There was three to five minutes that probably took some out of that.
Yeah.
They took it out of it delaying the start of the fifth round.
Cooper as always,
insisted that delay lasted anywhere from three to five minutes and denied him
the chance to try to knock out clay if he didn't even know what time it was.
That's when they showed the highlight the replay in that,
in that clip.
If he didn't know what,
wait where he was,
he would've been gone that next round.
Yeah.
As soon as it started,
it would have been out.
Maybe one haymaker try and that's it.
It's interesting,
man is interesting.
It's crazy that that,
you know,
that changed the course of history and for the other guy too,
for that British guy fall.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck.
He's like,
I could've beaten Ali and I did,
but no one ever knows it.
Yeah.
I mean basically he was like one punch away from Keio victory.
But who knows if he would've landed that punch at the beginning of the round,
legit.
I mean,
who knows?
Ali wouldn't have been able to talk to them about three to five minutes.
He didn't know where it was,
didn't know where he was.
And they use smelling salts about to bring them out.
You get one minute,
right?
Yeah.
They were about to bring him out.
Come on.
Deaf.
He was gone.
It's definitely illegal.
You can't do that shit
dude.
I was at your place once your old place and uh,
we were watching some,
some pride and then uh,
it ended early.
The recording ended or the DVR fucked it up.
Right.
Dvrs do fuck stuff up so well,
especially if you don't tell them to like record a,
it didn't used to be an option instead of the record,
the next show.
Oh to get it all.
Okay.
But um,
so we've got some pride event and it didn't finish the championship fight.
It didn't record that everything else went longer.
You know,
it's like fuck,
we're all disappointed.
I remember I forgot who the fight was,
but they're like,
oh well this does some heavyweight title fight in a for one belt or something.
We can watch that and have that recorded.
We watched that and after watching a bunch of mixed martial arts,
it was so boring and it was a decent fight.
But it was so boring.
Yeah.
There can be a lot of board and watching fights,
man hands.
Well if a guy's not a destroyer like Tyson was in that video,
you watched Tyson in that video.
That was exciting.
All those guys,
he was just a different dude.
But there was too like NBC way to go cause they fucking Paul put the
heavyweights [inaudible] well Mayweather and Pacquiao will be exciting just
because of the sheer magnitude of the historical event.
Immune.
That's a giant historical event.
Those two guys getting down.
Finally it'll be something that you watch just for that.
But when it all said and done like you gonna to watch again,
watch it a second
time.
You know,
I've watched a lot of MMA fights a second time and it's very interesting.
It's only a few boxing fights it,
I'll do that with,
but this weekend they made a big play on NBC.
They had NBC live fights.
They're having live fights.
What?
Boxing?
Yeah,
they're having live worldclass boxing.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah.
So they had um,
they used to have that.
I remember he used to watch it was just like,
so they're doing it a time or something.
Well I think the NBC is recognized.
I mean,
did they have the contender,
was that NBC,
the boxing story about possibly maybe ABC,
I don't know.
Oxygen Network.
Anyway,
they have now.
I think they see the UFC does really good numbers on Fox and like,
Hey,
you know,
there's some big name fights out there to be made.
So they put together uh,
some,
you know,
Pretty d Adrian Broner versus John Molina went to a decision,
boring fight and then they put um,
this guy,
um,
Keith Thurman who's this knockout artist versus Robert Guerra that went to
decision,
good fight but still went to a decision and nice.
But the Adrian Broner fibers,
like he was just kind of poking at him,
poking out on poke out.
I'm like,
it didn't,
never really,
never really had any danger.
He's just like,
just played it safe,
played it safe and pit lame.
Yeah.
It wasn't fun to watch.
It wasn't too,
but there's an art to,
it certainly is a method to his martial art,
you know,
watching him using his boxing.
But you know,
I want to watch a guy like pack out of that coast fucks people up.
That's what I like.
One of the things you like washed about Pacquiao,
he puts combinations on mother fuckers.
Yeah.
I'm going to Thailand.
I want to go watch a fucking kickboxing fight in Thailand.
You gotta make videos.
You Bet.
Bet.
Bet at all they got that guy,
that guy.
Yeah.
Here.
Knock.
So cow.
Did I win or lose?
I don't know what I bet on.
Yeah.
Just bring some uh,
Thai lady boys with you to decipher everything before you hire them.
Yeah.
And film it with Vice Vice.
Go there.
A lady boy,
uh,
yeah,
chaperone you in a three piece suit because you have money now and decide to go
to Thailand and live up your dreams,
which is to go to see an MMA fighter or a Moy Thai fight with some Thai lady
boys.
Yeah.
And they teach you how to make a video of that.
And with that note,
ladies and gentleman this week,
uh,
this is not happening.
It's 12:30 AM on Thursday evenings.
Um,
you are special.
Midnight.
My special home is available right now.
Yeah.
It's also,
it's available for presale right now are the great,
but this special is the one I did.
This is the first special after I did my,
my CD where I was like,
let me try to write a new hour starting now,
let me see if I can do this in a year.
Really concentrate and that's when my first year on the road.
So I was able to really like get a lot more time and that's why I did the
knitting factory and uh,
it was like limited release where nobody saw it.
So I'm doing it for however much you want to pay.
If you already paid for it,
it's a minimum of a dollar than pay a dollar if you can't find anymore.
And if you really love them,
give me 50 bucks,
whatever the fuck you want.
They'll like,
I don't know about this.
I was like,
let's just try it as a method.
Let's try it and see if people pay or not.
They'll pay.
Yeah.
It's stuff man.
And it's
a,
it's for you as a,
as a comic,
it's like,
it represents like what you really just sort of launched yourself,
you really sort of with,
with hard work and focus,
you just became a much better comic.
And you started killing and you started headlining on the road and you start
developing an audience and through podcasts and all this shit,
it's all just sort of come together,
man.
I have one or two bits in there that I'm like,
fuck yeah,
I'm really proud of those just chicken bit.
You'll see the comments again.
They did.
It was like eight and a half minutes.
Can you please put the whole bit in there?
And they were like,
yes.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
so watch it midnight this Friday night
and go to our,
the great.com for tour dates and all that shit.
He's traveling all over the place in Sacramento.
Australia is called Australia.
He gives zero fucks in DC.
Tons of places.
Oh,
we Mondo fucked in chef [inaudible].
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thanks.
Thanks everybody.
Take care.
We'll see you soon.
Mike slapped it on the show to Joe.
I love it because everybody,
wow.
Yes.